[Musique]
ACS c'est la meilleure avec en fait
c'est ce que j'aime bien dans ces
streams là qui sont assez longs on parle
de tout
et voilà et voilà non non
fin du stream voilà on a bien travaillé
on a
exactement en plus on était vraiment à
fond sur les échecs avec cette
discussion autour du soccer du soccer
voilà vous avez compris ce que c'était
en tout cas
est-ce qu'il faut être un bon sportif
pour jouer aux échecs non pas
nécessairement on voit qu'il y a des
différentes conditions chez le genre
d'échec mais c'est quand même conseillé
de s'entretenir Laurent Yann nous disait
qu'avec manus il faisait régulièrement
du sport Marius aime le sport je pense
que pour bien jouer aux échecs c'est
mieux d'être équilibré en tout point
voilà ça nous permet d'être constant
de bien s'alimenter et de faire du sport
esprit sain dans un corps sain
même Sana ou corporé ça non magnifique
j'espère que tu m'as pas insulté en
latin parce que sinon j'y vois que du
feu j'oserais pas je vais prendre
anglais au pire
pour pour que j'ai une chance quoi pour
que j'ai une chance
donc là cavalier 7 j'aime bien le coup
du petit Prague voilà il y a une
anticipation
des dessins on a vu que c'était un thème
clé de se séparer du pion des cartes en
jouant des 5
pour profiter du meilleur jeu de pièces
que nous décrivez le riz tout à l'heure
il y a toujours le problème du foot à 8
menace éventuellement cavalier preuve
carte aussi si maintenant
on a des cloué sympa sympa
comment est-ce qu'on va je sais pas trop
on va laisser peut-être réfléchir manus
est-ce ouh là là il y a comme une bombe
une bombe là
si H4 est en règle générale thématique
dans les pions isolés c'est à dire
l'attaque du roi noir là le roi noir il
a même pas ok que Magnus nous balance
déjà un gros H4 waouh passe mais en même
temps il y a G6 Fatou donc il a envie un
monde d'y aller je sais pas encore
comment mais
il a décidé de mettre la pression sur le
petit Prague vous voyez un Magnus il est
vraiment il a envie de faire une partie
agressive à tout ça
on voit bien là n'est pas il est pas là
pour
dormir c'est intéressant en plus c'est
jouer très rapidement
donc ouais il y va j'ai hâte de voir sa
bastonne salut Malek salut à tous ceux
qui nous rejoignent on a une petite
coupure de stream vous l'avez constaté
mais on a récupéré maintenant les
joueurs avec un Magnus Carlsen hyper
agressif
normalement on en discutait hier avec
Laurent on parlait de la technique
sensationnelle de Magnus par rapport aux
autres joueurs du top niveau il est plus
technique mais il se débrouille on va
dire ça comme ça en calcul puisqu'il est
champion du monde de rapides et champion
du monde de Blitz donc ça reste aussi un
des meilleurs calculateur dans
la planète échec voilà donc il a les
deux Magnus et là il a décidé de faire
le gros bourrin aujourd'hui on parlait
du Gros Bois au soccer non non j'ai un
style fin en soccer quelqu'un tout à
l'heure me demander quel était mon style
au soccer la finesse l'élégance
l'élégance l'élégance non mais là en ce
moment
un peu dans mon point il va falloir ça
ça me turlupine un petit peu et ça nuire
gravement à mes performances au soccer
là je suis en train de remettre en place
un cadre très strict au niveau de
l'hygiène de vie qui va me permettre de
d'exceller au niveau du soccer et aussi
d'avoir des des parties aux échecs au
prochain Top 16 de qualité je l'espère
en tout cas on voit Magnus bah il fait
son breton Magnus aujourd'hui hein c'est
plus le Norvégien technique c'est le
Breton bourrin il balance h4a5 alors que
le centre est ouvert enfin tout
normalement on fait plutôt les attaques
à l'aile de gros bourrin quand le centre
est fermé et là on voit
je pense que Maggie c'est le mauvais
exemple pour les pour les débutants au
niveau de des respects de principes et
tout parce que lui il va Assassin's quoi
c'est le niveau de compréhension
incroyable qui permet ça mais du coup
c'est magnifique c'est magnifique mais
difficile à
interpréter
énormément parce qu'en fait c'est très
très profond ce qui fait alors là on
peut dire oui il joue agressif mais
on peut pas voir toute la finesse de ce
qu'il a derrière la tête
il voulait éclater le petit Prague voilà
voilà comment il voit les choses alors
ce qu'on peut dire quand même c'est que
pour le moment Prague ne pouvait pas
apprendre le 4 parce que c'est bien de
prendre les fous surtout un fou
magnifique au centre ils avaient un
problème sur la case F6 voilà si je vais
le montrer à tout le monde un cavalier
34 cavalier 34 comment je gère le
problème alors j'ai peut-être voilà non
j'ai rien du tout j'ai rien du tout F6
ou cavalier F6 arrive c'est dégueu c'est
dégueu damasin qu'il y a B4 ça ne gère
pas le problème je vais me prendre le
carnetisme où on décide même peut-être
donc c'était moche donc je peux pas
prendre
Magnus salut à tous ici
[Musique]
c'est parce qu'il considère qu'il est
fort au centre il est fort au centre
donc l'adversaire ne pourra pas réagir
voilà pourquoi il se permet de pousser
H4 H5 attaque à elle en prévision d'un
petit noir
et Prague il est malin il fait à schiste
donc Magnus il a pas envie de reculer
son fou parce que maintenant je pourrais
le prendre très différent F4 je peux
prendre E4 prise 4 installer monsieur le
cavalier en dessin ou en F5 j'ai plus de
problème sur les cases ça irait donc la
Magnus fait F6 premier F6
et il a un une super domination à chaque
fois c'est la même ou c'est 8 contre x4
praguemalin quand même Lorie il a joué
cette structure là pour pouvoir en cas
de H5 ou CG5
l'idée
aussi on essaye de balancer
le plus vite
sur le sur le rock sur les pions du rock
mais il faut faire attention parce que
en fait à ne pas bloquer la position et
bloquer la position bah si le fait de
laisser ces pions sur la même la même
rangée ça permet que s'il y en a un qui
est poussé l'autre va avancer on va se
retrouver avec du coup des pions bloqués
en fait entre et donc ça permet de jouer
dans l'autre côté
et derrière il y avait trompe qui
voulait faire un 5 en disant on va
trouver les cases blanches
en fait on a le temps avant de le faire
sur la 5 et Magnus il a joué un coup
brillant qui va beaucoup de plaire je
pense bon de toute façon on prend pas de
risque un trou moins si c'est le coup de
Magnus ça va aller ça doit pas être une
grosse boulette il a joué Dame des deux
je trouve ça hyper malin il fait super
Prague avec sa dame juste à 6 et l'idée
mère toi Prague parce que tu as plus le
petit rock voilà petite pression à tout
moment maintenant il peut faire grand
rock ou pas il a un roi hyper souple
pour l'instant Magnus dans ces positions
complexes où les joueurs n'ont pas ok
et même si pragm mettait son roi en
petit je pense qu'il recréerait pas
nécessairement tout de suite alors c'est
pas c'est pas impossible mais c'est
aussi dans les positions complexes très
intéressantes le riz d'avoir le roi en 1
parce que je peux laisser au milieu je
peux grand roquet je peux dire ok je
donne pas mon adresse dans les positions
complexes garder son roi au milieu c'est
une technique d'expert c'est le un des
secrets
des grands maîtres dans les positions
complexes c'est garder son roi au milieu
pour finalement ne pas se faire attaquer
et si mon adversaire m'attaque au milieu
je me casse d'un des deux côtés donc ça
c'est hyper intéressant mais ne le
faites pas dans les positions classiques
ne le faites pas non plus si votre droit
au milieu il y a une grosse colonne
ouverte et qui va se faire taper dessus
la Magnus il voit que cette colonne là
est fermée il y a pas de problème
donc qui peut se permettre de narguer et
de laisser son roi au niveau du centre
c'est ça
mais ouais c'est le monde créatif de ce
type de position pourquoi pas le roi en
E2 pour l'instant il est très bien parce
que il peut roquer des deux côtés je le
trouve très très souple dans cette
position complète et cette partie elle
va quand même être hyper intéressante et
on a vu que Prague était très doué en
technique et pour une fois ma nu ce qui
aime bien jouer sur le registre
technique il a dû juger que c'était un
des points forts de son adversaire
Magnus on sait qu'il est fort partout il
aime quand même la baston il a dit
aujourd'hui ce sera baston j'ai les
blancs et je dois absolument gagner
parce que Magnus même si il a fait un
tournoi en demi teinte par rapport à ses
performances habituelles bah il se dit
que sisso fait un résultat contre
il pourrait complètement revenir dans la
course même à la gagne le podium c'est
clair il est il est dans la course quoi
qu'il arrive faut pas perdre aujourd'hui
mais quoi qu'il arrive il va être dans
la course au PO
par contre lui ce qu'il veut un
compétiteur comme Magnus c'est la
première place très clairement et il a
ses chances
il a bien joué son truc il était mal
mais il est bien bien remonté et ça peut
le jouer de rondes encore ça peut c'est
possible tout est possible
mais celle-là ça dépend pas que lui donc
on va voir le résultat de l'autre partie
avec les favoris du moins les premiers
on m'a proposé Caval et C6 c'est titit
qui a envie de jouer ça j'ai des coups
candidats un grand rock est-ce que
j'avais dit qu'on allait garder
l'adresse d'un droit grand rock c'est un
coup
tour D1 qui paraît quand même pas mal et
il y a aussi le dessin qu'à regarder à
chaque fois si on est de plus en plus
proche d'un dessin qu'à un moment pour
les blancs mais faudrait être vraiment
prêt et là le fait d'avoir notre rôle au
centre c'est hyper compliqué à juger
même si j'ai disais que c'était une
technique des forts grands maîtres et
des forts joueurs aux échecs en règle
générale des joueurs d'élite
ben c'est quand même compliqué à gérer
même pour ma news il va devoir bien
réfléchir au choix d'ouvrir le centre
alors qu'il a son centre
une cible réelle à l'adversaire donc un
point de vue
d'être plus défini parce que du coup on
sait où est le roi et on sait on va
aller mais du coup ça l'empêche un petit
peu d'ouvrir parce que il est encore au
centre donc c'est
normalement on dit aux joueurs amateurs
Rocket après attaquer et là on voit que
le mec il se permet d'attaquer avec son
gros au centre en fait c'est encore plus
malin et le roi au centre parce que là
le centre ne gêne pas le développement
des pièces blanches on a pu se
développer quasiment entièrement il y a
juste à tour H1 et même à la limite
cette tour achat pour avoir des idées
soient d'ouvrir la colonne soit passer
par là même ça tourne là elle pourrait
se développer donc en fait ce roi souple
et hyper hyper malin seulement vous
jouez tel un acrobate ce genre de
position c'est erikasi que stuff appelle
comme ça l'acrobase il faut avoir un
calcul hyper précis pour ne pas se
prendre les pieds dans le tapis c'est
pour ça qu'on conseille aux amateurs de
Rocket
et c'est un bon conseil
parce que
faire ce genre de partie comme le fait
Magnus c'est réservé normalement aux
joueurs d'élite allez je dirais plus de
2000 2002 parce que sinon c'est hyper
risqué c'est peut-être même
contre-productif même si la décision
initiale est un intéressante il va vous
faire des années de pratique
un calcul très propre pour pouvoir jouer
comme ça sur le fil du rasoir si là
Magnus s'envoie un moment l'air avec des
cinq ben en fait ça ira parce que lui
aura calculé toutes les conséquences
proprement alors que si c'est un joueur
amateur qui n'a pas les notions de
calcul suffisantes bah ça peut vite être
une boulette et on peut vite se
retrouver
dans une position très complexe voilà à
gérer
ok je ne suis pas mal Magnus nous dit
Eva je vais continuer de roquet
c'est intéressant de regarder ça parce
que le concept est créatif mais il est
pas non plus pour l'instant incroyable
par contre on va voir qu'à un moment ça
va être très chaud ça va être très chaud
et oui tant que vous avez pas
l'expérience suffisante
tant que déjà il y a des problèmes de
vérification dans vos parties c'est quoi
les problèmes de vérification c'est que
vous filez du matériel jouer simple déjà
essayé de comprendre quelle est
l'urgence de la position qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire dans la position c'est
souvent améliorer ces pièces par exemple
un bon conseil et ne rien donner faire
tourner votre radar tactique pour ne pas
vous prendre de tactique ce qu'on
conseille majoritairement aux joueurs
débutants début d'amateur Lorie c'est de
faire de la tactique pour être propre
évidemment la tactique c'est la base
c'est l'essentiel et puis respecter les
principes on en parle aussi mercredi
dans l'ouverture vous avez pas besoin de
connaître les ouvertures ou si vous
respectez les principes tout va bien se
passer et puis après il faut jouer donc
peu rappeler les trois principes
d'ouverture Kevin est-ce que tu les
connais
ouais j'en ai même un quatrième mais oui
je les connais le riz donc on prend le
centre c'est ça est-ce que j'ai bon la
première règle est-ce qu'on prend le
centre chez toi très bien on prend le
centre souvent avec un pion les pièces
mineures aussi qui vont qui vont aller
contrôler les cases du centre ok bah
d'ailleurs tu as spoilé mon deuxième
principe mais c'est normal un chacun
aussi un chacun donc on va sortir les
pièces mineures et Lorie vous dit
quelque chose
d'intéressant pour les plus débutants
d'entre vous vers le centre quand même
et je vais rajouter encore plus et c'est
d'embêter vos adversaires en sortant vos
pièces ce que j'appelle les coups
piquants je pense que ça parle à tout le
monde c'est vous donner des petits coups
de pied avec vos pièces quand vous les
sortez ça va embêter l'adversaire qui ne
pourra pas faire ce qu'il veut c'est la
base les coups piquants les coups de
pression les coût menaçants vous appelez
ça comme vous voulez mais ça veut à peu
près dire la même chose vous embêterez à
l'adversaire pour pas dire autre chose
et c'est excellent
troisième critère normalement en rock et
on voit que Magnus aujourd'hui Lorie il
n'a pas roquet mais on a compris
pourquoi il le faisait oui il peut se
permettre lui on accélère
et le 4e principe que je ne vois pas
assez dans les parties des joueurs
amateurs c'est d'activer vos pièces
lourdes les tours et les dames
sur les colonnes ouvertes ça c'est
facile généralement ça c'est transparent
pour tout le monde ou sur les colonnes
qui vont s'ouvrir c'est à dire quand il
y a des pions qui s'entretchent ce qu'on
appelle une tension de pion essayez de
mettre vos tours là où ça va s'ouvrir
c'est la base de la partie de Carsen où
est-ce qu'on doit mettre nos tours
alors il n'y a pas de tension là Laurie
mais on sait déjà où ça se passe alors
la tour par exemple voilà la tour achat
on a un peu embêté pour l'instant avec
parce qu'on n'a pas trop envie de roquet
un petit peu pourquoi pas ça peut être
une tour d'attaque avec ce genre de plan
à chaque ouverture de la colonne mais il
y aura G5 le mec est pas si bête en face
il va pas activer notre tour par contre
celle-là c'est facile il y a une colonne
ouvertes mais ma tour quasiment pilote
auto ici et cette tour là normalement
s'il y avait pas sur H4 et toute cette
histoire il y aurait plutôt en D1
derrière le pion pour pour les colonnes
qui vont s'ouvrir d'ailleurs Laurie
c'est c'est intéressant je pense
c'est là où
mais aussi ouvert où on va ouvrir parce
que c'est là que nos tours qu'on pourra
avoir un plus gros impact derrière les
pions derrière les pièces effectivement
il faut
elle dorme elle dort et c'est vrai que
effectivement comme tu dis bah chez les
plus débutants souvent on tarde à avoir
assez tours rentrer dans le jeu la dame
on voit plus souvent mais les tours
on a du mal à les faire rentrer à leur
faut bien y penser une fois que vous
avez développé vos pièces si vous avez
Rocket le centre d'un moment il faut
il faut faire jouer tout le monde il
faut inviter tout le monde à la fête
donc les tours aussi et exactement sur
la case de prédilection
c'est pas bête non plus les trois les
trois colonnes là surtout qu'on a la
poussée des cinq un jour ça semble
logique voilà
et si ça pourrait exister aussi il
existe grand rock
c'est chaud grand requin parce que
roquet
sur cette c'est chaud on joue
grand rock et on amène la tour là et on
fait les gros bourrins on fait G4 et on
faut que ça éclate dans ce cas là
[Musique]
donc faut être sûr d'ouvrir si je
m'engage avec mes tours sur des colonnes
fermées ça a été proposé dans le chat
voilà
du coup du coup
si ça s'ouvre pas j'ai trop merdé quoi
je suis désolé il y a pas d'autres mots
j'ai complètement déconné ça sauf pas
j'ai engagé mes tours et sur des
colonnes fermées j'ai des élèves des
fois d'ailleurs qui me font les tours
sur les colonnes fermées et souvent je
suis un petit peu moqueur je leur dis
merci de m'apprendre des choses voilà
pour pour leur dire c'est bizarre mais
de les tours sur la colonne fermée alors
souvent il y a une bonne idée enfin
l'élève a une bonne idée parce qu'il
faut des idées aux échecs même des
mauvaises en fait la bonne idée elle
fonctionne pas elle fonctionne pas donc
placer majoritairement vos tours sur les
colonnes ouvertes sur les colonnes qui
vont s'ouvrir si c'est les colonnes qui
vont s'ouvrir faut pas que ça soit trop
abstrait faut que ce soit justement
concret quand vous dites ça va s'ouvrir
ça va vraiment sourire faut pas que ce
soit une blague après
bah c'est triste parce que manger
du lourd ailleurs
bah c'est facile à comprendre vous êtes
le général de votre armée il faut que
vos pièces parlent quoi c'est ce qu'on
dit si vos pièces sont belles elles vous
aideront voilà globalement l'idée donc à
vous de bien les manier c'est pas si
facile on joue depuis très très
longtemps avec avec le riz aux échecs et
du coup c'est ce qui permet de mieux
sentir les choses et encore bah voilà on
a des problèmes certaines fois je pense
que c'est le moment peut-être de faire
un petit tour des échiquiers on s'est
focalisé pour l'instant
chez
Abdou Sator Rohff et Wesley
et Carlsen on va peut-être maintenant
aller voir les autres parties est-ce que
tu es d'accord le riz est-ce que j'ai
hâte mon chouchou allez
qui joue Fabiano Caruana voilà donc
Vincent Kemer
Fabiano avec les pièces blanches et
Vincent Kemer avec beaucoup d'avance à
la pendule avec les pièces noires qui
sont déjà on voit la jauge vous savez
qu'on a cette terrible jaune qu'on fait
les analyses sans les sans les variantes
de l'ordinateur comme ça c'est vraiment
des analyses humaines et on va voir
comment s'est passé on reconnaît comme
une Espagnole voilà
assez basique pour l'instant
du grand classique alors l'espagnol D3
des fois c'est ces trois D4 qui est
privilégié mais des trois ça va très
bien aussi de toute façon à terme on
aura ces trois D4 ok donc ces trois
arrivent petit rock H3 est joué pour
éviter fou G4 quand on joue croit des 4
ça c'est marrant de dire que j'ai 4
n'est jamais bon dans l'espagnol tant
que les Blancs n'ont pas joué des cartes
parce que on se fait on peut dire c'est
vraiment pas conseillé de jouer fougères
c'était quoi le coup d'avant allez ici
ce genre de coup il y a des H3 et votre
fou se retrouverait parce que j'ai pas
envie de donner ma paire de fou je
déteste ça alors je déteste tout ça
parce que c'est pas bon en règle
générale faut surtout pas le mettre le
fond à 5 dans l'espagnol parce que sinon
sur le long terme on peut se prendre des
G4 et se voir notre four enterré ici
peut-être pas tout de suite ce que je
pousse devant mon roi et je vais en
faire crier certains donc ce que je peux
montrer c'est que le plan dans
l'espagnol c'est aussi ce plan là hop je
vais maintenant et du coup le Fou est
toujours embêté
se retrouve enterré là par contre
sur petit rang les Blancs ne jouent pas
des cartes ici alors déjà il y a un
problème c'est les idées de fouger les
quatre ça devient bon faut que j'ai
quatre quand on appuie sur le pion d'A4
faut le savoir donc ça c'est des choses
que j'ai appris par le véhicule joueur
j'ai déjà mal placé mon G4 et du coup
ben j'ai compris pourquoi il était mal
placé par contre il est bien placé sur
des cartes parce que je tape le sens
donc on voit souvent faut que j'acc4
pression ici et si les blancs font des 5
alors il y a des cavaliers à 5 et on
pourra casser le centre ces exemples
thématiques de d'espagnol ici le riz des
thèmes spéciaux
important voilà donc petit rock on
comprend bien le H3 Fabian il connaît sa
Parker c'est vraiment très facile pour
lui cavalier A5 c'est normal
soit par cœur parce qu'on va essayer de
sont un peu machinalement mais ça c'est
un vrai impact dans les coups suivants
en fait c'est là qu'on voit la
profondeur de ce qu'on peut jouer
exactement et alors disons pour les
joueurs amateurs attention vous faites
vraiment les H3 et les petits A3
préventifs les petites portes dont on
parlait Laurent hier
ne le faites pas à toutes les sauces
vraiment c'est pour en plâcher c'est
pour empêcher pardon un clouage venimeux
c'est pas pour rien parce que vous savez
on aime bien avec Fatou les coups
piquants les coups de pression bref le
développement utile mais là il était
gêné par fougères dans son idée de
prendre le centre enfin tout nous
expliquer que c'était un des grands
principes
donc c'est logique ici à froid mais à
trois je veux pas le voir pour l'instant
il y en a qui font à 3 et je crois
quasiment dans tous les parties non vous
perdez du temps ah oui c'est utile
en fait quoi de méfiant mais pas peureux
c'est la phrase clé méfiant vous devez
faire tous les vérifications possibles
mais pas peureux et pareil des menaces
inexistantes allez c'est 5 c'est le coup
logique c'est le coût cavalier A5
contrôle du centre
et là une mini bombe de
Kemer je connais pas exactement la
position
des 5
ah oui puissance 4 c'est gagné
je pense que la partie que ça a été là
bon il y a ces idées là dans l'espagnol
mais pas du tout dans ce genre de
position c'est plutôt ouais ça c'est
pour ça que ça ressemble à une Espagnole
un peu ouverte cette histoire en fait
cette position s'appelle on est plutôt
dans ce qu'on appelle les Espagnols
fermés les blancs à terme peuvent avoir
des idées de dessin qui permet au centre
et un moment rapatrier toutes leurs
pièces à l'ailer le roi même avec du G4
cavalier G3 et construire quelque chose
sur le roi et demi
d'où espagnol fermé qui sera au centre
et là dans cette position d'espagnol
fermé le coût de dessin de Kemer alors
faudrait que je regarde avec la base de
données
je ne connais pas je suis pas
spécialiste je joue la sienne à titre
perso j'ai quand même des élèves qui
jouent l'espagnol et du coup je suis
hyper intéressé par ce choix de Vincent
piémer gros boxon au centre mais en même
temps enfin tout ça a du sens parce que
les pièces de Fabiano sont pas trop
prêtes donc on met le bazar au centre
c'est pas mal pas mal
[Musique]
une grosse prise d'espace tentative de
prise d'espace en gros avec ses avancées
mais attention
attention il va
impressionnant moi je trouve j'ai jamais
vu ça j'ai jamais vu cette position
précisément
on gagne pas un pion si on prend un
cavalier prend un 4 en fait on a répondu
au D4 qui menaçait le pion E5 par D5 qui
menace
le pion E4
donc le coût qui pourrait être malin
c'est de prendre en dessin
et comme ça après je me dis je vais me
gagner le Pione 5 sauf que sur reprend
des 5 il y a eux prend des cartes c'est
l'idée de Vincent Kemer je pense comme
sans regagne des cinq on peut prendre
des je peux le montrer je pense que
c'est eux prend dès le coup logique et
comme ça je reprends ce pion là
alors
il a joué 5
c'est pas mal Desproges parce que ça
élimine le cavalier défenseur du roi
déjà cavalier prend un 4 et je te dis
vas-y tu veux bien me donner ton fou
qu'on de mon super cavalier
en fait j'ai pas trop envie avec les
Blancs ça ne me dit pas de donner mon
joli fou
c'est jouable quand même parce que c'est
intéressant d'essayer de gagner après le
Pione 4 mais ça marche pas quoi je
n'arrive pas à le gagner là puis on
prend je suis obligé de là on voit
clairement le manque d'espace et là j'ai
fou B7 et j'ai même E3 intergressant
c'est la cagoule
nouveau 4 Fantastiques
je parle de ça sur 4 un sicilienne 4 5 4
C6 la carro ou la française mais là on a
vu une belle prouesse alors qu'est-ce
qu'il fallait jouer sur 4 moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il joue très bien Fabien
ocarwana mais c'est pas une grande
nouvelle que je vous dis là cavalier BD2
il voit une belle pièce de l'adversaire
il attaque F5 très malin
mais très malin mais qu'est-ce qu'on a
prévu surtout re-1 parce que il y a
grosse pression
il y a grosse pression mais c'est
peut-être pas si gagnant que ça Lorie
parce que
il y a un vis-à-vis Damdam et ça
m'empêche peut-être de prendre
facilement le pion et cavalier 6 jouets
alors on peut se demander Laurie si on
pouvait pas y aller est-ce qu'on pouvait
pas y aller
justement ça c'est ce qu'on disait au
début là faut calculer plus de coups le
calcul par r assez simple regardez je
vois que j'ai trois attaques sur le sur
le terrier il y a que deux défenseurs
donc j'ai envie de le croquer bien sûr
faut pas que je déconne parce que il y a
madame en D1 vis-à-vis de l'autre dame
donc regardez ce que je calcule qui est
allié prend puis on prend et si je
prends comme un imbécile en E4 je perds
la partie on fait d’âme prend des un je
vais faire une pièce donc j'intercale
donc coin intermédiaire d'un pandam mon
adversaire reprend je pense de sa tour a
et là je crois que le pion
voilà
alors là je gagnais un pion du coup
maintenant
on peut estimer qu'il y avait des
compensations noires sinon Vincent Kemer
ton chouchou Laurie il aurait pas laissé
faire ça qu'est-ce qu'on a comme
compensation
qu'est-ce que tu verrais
[Musique]
si on échange on peut rentrer on peut
rentrer bien sûr on n'a pas trop le
choix je pense qu'on a deux pièces
attaquer on va on va échanger et
provoquer tout reprend
après qu'est-ce que ça nous fait si on
rentre en D1 donc est-ce qu'on peut
échanger si la tour recule attention
on pourrait échanger des tours et là sur
le pion E5 ne serait plus protégé
donc si la tour recule
si
on a beaucoup d'activités en échange de
pions
voilà voir si il y a d'autres
possibilités mais
la tournée est bien placée et en fait si
c'est la question si on essaye de de la
bouger on peut pas parce qu'on peut
faire le pion E5 et de me montrer autre
chose le cavalier en E1 ou le roi H2
bon où est-ce qu'on va mais après vous
voyez on est paralysé en fait donc
Vincent tous les jours je prends les
Noirs parce que il y a tour des 8 tours
de 3 tours des 5 on peut embêter
l'espion là et on est paralysé avec les
les blancs
les autres le placement la tour en le 4
on a parlé du placement des tours on
veut qu'elle soit placées ou sur l'école
ouverte qui vont s'ouvrir
clairement là les tournois peuvent
totalement remplir ça mais les blanches
donc on a trouvé notre compensation on
parle Lorie d'harmonie entre les pièces
et là les pièces blanches elles sont pas
coordonnées soit on parle de
coordination des pièces dans le registre
activité des pièces après tour des 8 le
cavalier et les centrales il fait
pression sur le petit pion E5 les tours
sont sur colonne vertes il y en a une
qui est rentrée c'est la régalade avec
les pièces les pièces noires on a même
c'est juste le 7 qui me gênerait
peut-être qu'on peut lui trouver un plan
comme ça tiens un fiancetto pour appuyer
sur la faiblesse bon vous voyez en tout
cas ce que Vincent kemmer avait vu il
était très très bien préparé ça y est il
commence à réfléchir Vincent kemmer je
pense que là ils connaissait la position
il y a eu cavalier F1 de Fabiano
grand classique amélioration des pièces
et C4 dans la structure alors ça fait un
pion des 5 faible mais il a vu que son
fou il n'était pas génial ces autres
pièces si les aiment bien je pense qu'il
veut coller peut-être le fond c'est
simple
est-ce toujours l'histoire de
compensation là il donne il donne où il
lèche une cible
en dessin à l'adversaire
on n'aime pas forcément mais il a un
plan il a un plan et l'activation du
fond notamment c'est fou qu'on ne met
pas trop dans la variante juste avant
tout à fait donc
une compensation il sait où il joue
pourquoi pas
donc bon là vous voyez et puis il y a
aussi l'idée B4 structurellement qui
serait très intéressant parce que je
fais pression sur ce pion là en C3 et si
je prends il y aura big centre
voilà pour pour les pour les noirs avec
un pion qui pourrait commencer même à
s'envoler donc c'est très intéressant
karwana pas bête il est vite tous les
Foussais
et du coup ça donne envie déjà de
commencer à les aider à base de B4
je pense qu'il a il a des idées aussi de
foudre Fabiano parce que c'est quand
même son mauvais fou et si je prends le
carvalier prend c'est plutôt sympa
Fugees d'anticipation
et cavalier j'ai trois joué par Fabiano
Caruana beaucoup plus étonnant et on
arrive dans cette position ou Vincent
Kemer réfléchit pour la première fois
cavalier 3 c'est difficile à expliquer
pour moi la première fois que je suis
gêné aujourd'hui par un coup
si tu veux le riz à cause de la
structure justement
du coup c'est toi qui va expliquer ce
que c'est la première fois que je suis
gêné et ça rejoint la notion tu es très
forte la notion de structure de pions
j'ai du mal à comprendre à cause de tu
vas m'expliquer la structure j'ai hâte
là cette spécialité en plus donc tu es
en terrain
un petit coup de pression je suis désolé
c'est ça qu'il faut voir et sur
l'échange
on se retrouve avec des pions doublés un
pion isolé alors là
ça picote un peu les yeux ça pour les
principes ça tue un petit peu tout
notre eau est pas en danger les pions
doublés là sont pas un problème d'accord
il y a pas
parfois ils peuvent être des faiblesses
aussi s'il y a pas d'autres pions là
comme l'option Hatch pour les pour
travailler avec eux s'ils sont isolés
c'est un problème là c'est plutôt solide
mais ça pose la question aussi pour le
e qui lui est vraiment tout seul aussi
et
alors certes il a trouvé de protéger
mais on n'aime pas trop isolé si
facilement ses pions
pareil on ouvre la colonne F
alors que notre tour qui était en F au
départ la mise en E
donc
ça pose des questions aussi sur le
placement après bon si on regarde c'est
bizarre quand même comme choix et je
pense d'ailleurs que Fabiano sur sur
cavalier projet 3
excuse-moi excuse-moi
je t'en prie je t'en prie je t'en prie
on va on va encore avoir ton idée sur
les structures d'option mais je crois
que je me suis un peu trompé sur un
projet 3 mais je reviendrai j'ai prévu
de passer une heure dessus
connaître par les squelettes les
structures
non mais voilà en fait j'ai tout dit
j'ai résumé un petit peu mais c'est un
choix un peu étonnant structurellement
parlant
bah oui
t'as parlé de ce cavalier qui vient là
mais pas dans ce type de position et pas
avec une possibilité d'échange après ça
arrive jamais ça arrive jamais après tu
disais aussi que le cavalier en 4 était
pas fort et gênant c'est vrai
ça c'est vrai donc Fabiano fait une
concession au niveau de la structure
nous dit le riz mais on élimine la
meilleure pièce de l'adversaire et
peut-être que l'histoire quand même
c'est que sur cavalier projet 3 les
blancs peuvent intercaler il faut
prendre des 6 comme ça tu me fais des
pions je t'en fais aussi F prends je
pense pas même si ça active la tour ça
laisse ce pion là qui devient isoler
mais passer
pourra peut-être aller en bêta
l'adversaire ah je prends j'ai et je
reprends maintenant et j'aurais
peut-être toujours la pousser E6 pour me
débarrasser de ce pion avec fruits des
cas de toute façon je suis pas trop en
danger quand même ici avec des cartes
donc ok ça passe ça passe
depuis là au niveau du
four foncier
est-ce que tu conseilles toi et
débutants
un petit principe normalement on dit
toujours le rythme qui est spécialiste
déstructures reprises vers le centre je
pense que si tu voulais me faire dire
exactement mais tu as bien raison de
dire ça c'est un petit indicateur en
règle générale parfois vous allez voir
un fort grand maître prendre en G6 alors
que vous dites ouais mais on nous avait
dit qu'il fallait reprendre vers le
centre donc ah je prends G6 fait sens
ici
étranger si on voyait que le fait
d'activer la tour ça devient c'est hyper
important en fait ranger et puis la
remarque générale on la met à la
poubelle on va dire que dans 80% des cas
on fait h.g dans ce type de position
fonger là je pense que ces petites un
petit avantage blanc peut-être dans la
partie je constate que Vincent Kemer a
joué de B4
je suis ton plan
ça a l'air logique ça a l'air logique je
vérifie quand même
vérifie parce que voilà bien B4 je
vérifié mais pour moi c'est le c'est le
quiz père logique et cavalier 3 à cause
de Fougères 6 après pour un rendu en
terme de structure d'options le riz je
pense que c'est pour ça que ça a pas été
joué un pour qu'on explique bien donc on
a éditours des échiquiers tour des
échiquier il faut qu'on continue en tout
cas cette partie elle a l'air
intéressante pour ton poulain
il gagne pas forcément mais il faut
toujours bien parti très intéressante
qui tu veux aller voir il nous reste van
faux guéri dans donc van forest Jordan
contre Aniche Guéry duel des locaux
puisque ce sont les deux représentants
hollandais voilà il nous reste Richard
rapporte contre le prétendant titre
mondial digne
on n'a pas vu non plus goût Kesh et à
rognan et enfin max doudou qui a été
brillant hier contre un faible
pragnananda pour une fois c'est un
signalé qui joue un autre joueur indien
un des joueurs de mon club à Mulhouse
l'acrobate comme le surnom stuff ergy
alors qui tu vas les voir alors il sait
toi qui choisis c'est moi qui choisis
alors
et désolé connecté si si j'ai dit
néerlandais
j'ai dit hollandais et non néerlandais
il y a pas le droit de dire
hollandaise ici mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette position
je regarde cette position j'imagine
qu'il y a pas la jaune je donne avantage
noir parce que bon mon roi il peut ok
donc ça a l'air d'aller et je peux le
laisser au centre
et j'ai l'impression que j'ai une
qualité d'avance et qu'en plus au
dernier coup Danish guéri B6 me permet
d'ouvrir maintenant si on creuse un
petit peu
j'ai quand même mon Roi au milieu de
l'échiquier et c'est peut-être pas si
simple que ça de ok peut-être que c'est
pas si simple en fait parce qu'il peut y
avoir des attaques avec cavalier G5 donc
ça mérite d'être approfondie surtout
quand on voit la jauge bah ça on l'a pas
mais rien que le temps de Jordan van
forest nous montre qu'il a réussi à
planter une énorme prépa à neige gris il
a dû jouer quasiment tous ses coups à
tempo jusqu'au 20e on va aller voir la
surprise on est obligé alors
sur l'ouverture qui est la plus à la
mode en ce moment avec les noirs sur des
4 tout le monde à haut niveau alors tout
le monde beaucoup de joueurs au niveau
joue la défense donc du gambidam refusé
version ragosine on va expliquer ce que
c'est au début ça part comme une Nimzo
indienne avec plutôt les fous B4
là on peut plus jouer la Nimzo parce que
la Nimzo c'est sur ks-3 faire le clouage
on peut jouer soit fou
Bko indienne mais c'est délaissé à haut
niveau
la ouest indienne mais la pâte très
bonne réputation et Magnus en début de
tournois perdus une partie sur le sujet
donc on va éviter de jouer B6 donc les
joueurs pourront aussi jouer une
benonyme alors la Benoni c'est 5 ben on
donne le centre avec des 5 elle est pas
jouée au niveau donc en fait les joueurs
sur cavalier 3 retombent dans un
gambidam refusé ici Lorie qu'on pourrait
obtenir par des cas D5 C4 E6 la petite
subtilité dans la position qu'on a vu en
jouant l'ordre de coût des 4 cavaliers
F6 C4 E6 c'est qu'on provoque un valet
F3 alors que les blancs dans le gamme
refusaient en règle générale ne sont pas
obligés de le mettre en F3 sur certaines
variantes ils peuvent le mettre en E2
après avoir développé le fou voilà pour
les puristes des cinq a été joué c'est
prendre des on peut il y a pas de
problème on prend des pions de l'aile
compte pion du centre cavaler ces trois
et un des grands classiques ici avec les
noirs ou B4
le coût traditionnel que je connais ici
Laurie c'est fou G5 jouer à toutes les
sauces voilà ça fait sens avant de jouer
3 on développe notre fou et on clou
voilà est-ce que tu connais le riz la
position ici
est-ce que tu veux rajouter des choses
non
mais rien à rajouter effectivement
sortir les pièces avant avant les pions
ne pas enfermer ses pièces derrière ça
s'achève de pions c'est important
mais à part ça non
je t'en sors très bien je trouve pour
moi
en fait je vois que tu faisais la même
faute que moi et tu t'es fait reprendre
par du coup un Néerlandais
ou néerlandaise et du coup tu m'as
rebalancé à la figure ce que tu t'étais
pris ah oui il faut dans vos parties
d'échec c'est la même chose faut tirer
les leçons de vos erreurs et du coup
bien jouer connecter tu m'as eu
ok bref 4
déjà je suis je connais pas ce type de
position pourtant j'ai joué la ragosine
avec les noirs pour F4 et marginal
donc c'est ça l'histoire de la prépa de
de devant de Forest en plus il a invités
mais d'habitude le fouet en G5 plus
cavalier
en fait c'est une grosse prépa sans
doute on va voir mais il y a quelque
chose derrière
le fait il incite à faire un coup
logique exactement mais il a préparé du
coup ok donc elle va laisser 6 pourquoi
pas et là H4 déjà c'est un peu plus
bizarre
dans cette position parce qu'on attaque
le vent
puisque les noirs n'ont pas encore
roqués
à peu près la théorie quand même les
joueurs sont tellement forts
eux trois jours ouais
il y a quand même une idée importante
dans cette position quand même c'est
important j'en parle quand je vois le
coup de H4 c'est pas tant pour l'attaque
c'est aussi pour peut-être
valider il y a des G5 thématiques dans
dans les positions qui peuvent arriver
sur des coups comme E3 regardez je vais
vous montrer quand même parce que l'idée
du coup H4 c'est peut-être une idée
défensive Lorie sur trois si je veux
trois normalement il y a du G5 sans un
thème connu bon faut 5 j'ai pas envie de
le jouer déjà il y a des F6
saisir de mon fou et surtout j'ai trois
je pense que vous connaissez peut-être
dans le chat ce thème là Lorie est-ce
que tu sais comment jouer cette position
avec les noirs
déjà on a donné un gros indice avec ce
gros G5 balancer un peu à
l'emporte-pièce coup de gros bourrin et
il faut absolument connaître ce thème
qui existe dans plusieurs ouvertures
blanc et noir confondus
donc en fait c'est plutôt un coup de
défense H4 je pense par rapport au thème
d'Annie
alors alors
des idées et oui Arnaud a trouvé trombe
à trouver
et il y a Aulas qui nous fait un petit
qui nous fait un petit sondage pendant
ce temps là du coup oui Sacha regardez
c'est magnifique à chaque je vise
l'enfermement du Fou Laurie je provoque
donc la petite porte
chair à Laurent hier quand il s'agit de
défendre le match du couloir mais là
c'est la petite porte catastrophique
parce que la Lorie là tu vas exceller
normalement là c'est un spécialité là tu
es trop contente
et oui salut à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent dans le chat depuis le début
de ce stream
dis-moi tout alors
un petit échange qui nous paraît pas mal
et oui oui bien sûr c'est ça qu'on veut
et change elle parlait pas du cavalier
C3 elle veut piquer la paire de fou et
regardez
Pione 3 comment il s'appelle le 3 et me
répondait pas E3
Elisabeth
3 non c'est pas ça non plus
c'est un pion sur
tu fais les textes à trous exactement je
faisais
sur colonne semi-ouverte un pion arrière
il a ses copains pions devant lui ok pas
de souci on comprend il est donc pas
possible de le défendre avec des pions
c'est un pion mou c'est pas un pion doux
dur les pions dur ils sont défendus par
des pions et les pions mous mais on va
les attaquer et ça va réduire à
l'esclavage les pièces du défenseur donc
l'option E3 bah c'est vraiment horrible
il est arriéré et sur colonne
semi-ouverte ça va donner des accès à
mes tours pour venir l'attaquer avec mes
canons et du coup c'est hyper
désagréable en plus de cela le pion G3
il est bien nul aussi bonnet d'âne là il
y a le côté Matic je sais pas s'il faut
jouer fouder 6 ou dames des 6 le riz
mais en tout cas ce pion G3
bah c'est un pion doublé non protégé et
fixé on peut pas jouer G4 donc on bien
souvent des variantes thématiques je
sais pas si je vous décides ou
d'investisse allez fous des 6 ok je vais
vous F2 et du coup
ah je peux peut-être jouer cavalier 2
quand même ah du coup plutôt d'âme des 6
alors hop j'ai repris mon cou vous avez
rien vu je vous donne des 6 comme ça il
peut pas jouer cavalier 2 c'est beaucoup
plus précis
hop roi F2 forcée pour garder le pion
c'est dégueulasse il y a pas de moi on a
deux faiblesses on protège avec le roi
ça existe en finale mais pas dans ce
type de position j'ai complètement raté
mon ouverture donc le courage 4 qui
paraissait vraiment bizarre de vendre
forest on comprend très largement depuis
que le cavalier arrivait en 4
ça existe cette thématique
a été joué on va regarder la prépa
est-ce qu'on peut juste revenir sur sur
l'appellation
d'où ça existe pas du tout pion dur et
pion de mou
alors imaginons
je dis ça des fois à mes élèves pour
qu'ils comprennent les structures de
tout simplement alors
ça c'est dur comme du béton
pomme la jauge à pas aimé pourquoi parce
que j'ai donné un fort cavalier contre
le fou et le cavalier était bien plus
fort donc là c'est dur de chez dur quoi
voilà par contre dans la position qu'on
avait tout à l'heure bah ça c'est mou ça
c'est mou aussi ça peut pas être en fait
vos pions mou vous pouvez pas les
défendre avec vos pions bah du coup qui
va s'en occuper c'est vos pièces et
quand vos pièces vont s'en occuper mais
elles vont pas être belles elles vont me
mettre dégueu et du coup ben vous allez
vous faire taper dessus de toute part
parce que vous aurez une structure un
peu débile et en plus vous aurez des
pièces débiles allez trop de débilité
dans la proposition bah ça tue la
position voilà ce qu'on peut dire voilà
c'est comme le beurre doux elle est ça
c'était les pions
doux c'était un peu bizarre mais pion
durée pion mou oui c'est pour expliquer
les structures je pense que au final
c'est transparent voilà et du coup c'est
pas très très agréable cette position
là les gars que vous avez que ce soit à
vendre forest c'est pas des pigeons
c'est les deux meilleurs joueurs
néerlandais
il y a quand même pas il y avait fait
une belle génération de joueurs très
forts en Hollande au Pays-Bas je sais
plus quoi dire maintenant j'ai peur de
dire une bêtise
sur nos amis néerlandais mais en tout
cas on avait Smith on avait stelvagen
erwinnami et là on a guéri et vent de
Forest qui sont vraiment incroys et
maintenant qui font tous les gros
tournois donc foie F5 E3
rappelons que vent Forest a déjà gagné
le tata style c'était il y a 2 ans alors
que anis guéri et surnommé le Poulidor
de l'épreuve cinq fois deuxième voilà
donc du le Poulidor du Wim le donne des
échecs je vous laisse avec cette image
en tête E3 cavalier prend C3 B prend C3
attention regardez il s'est passé un
truc FF5 c'est vicieux
je coince la tour en fait et du coup sur
E3 jouer
trois fois trois
et vu la pendule de vente forest c'était
calculer c'était même sans doute prévu
on file pas comme ça une qualité
franchement quand on regarde cette pause
on se dit punaise mais c'est donner quoi
c'est cadeau sauf qu'il se passe un truc
à ce moment-là oui la qualité est perdue
le riz mais il peut choisir contre
quelle foule à donner cette qualité la
qualité c'est différent tout ré fou
c'est ça alors contre quel fou la donnée
est-ce que tu vois le choix qu'il a fait
je le vois pas alors je l'ai pas vu
mais
faut chercher la logique exactement
lequel nous dérange le plus super
on va parler de on va parler de valeur
relative des pièces si vous voulez
normalement une tour s'efforme mais là
la tour en C1 bah de toute façon elle
était triste quel est le meilleur fou de
votre adversaire et vous donnerez
contre le meilleur fou c'est logique en
fait
tes réponses
et oui contrôle le flou blanc contre le
flou blanc parce que les cases blanches
sont très ouvertes
donc on donne en jouant tour B1 et tout
à l'heure le riz je parlais des coups
piquants
c'est un sujet que j'aime beaucoup
l'initiative dans les ouvertures mais
pas que dans les ouvertures là on est en
fin d'ouverture les développements des
joueurs sont quasiment effectués le rock
est quasiment réalisé donc on est en fin
de l'ouverture début du milieu de jeu et
tourbéen on donne c'est vrai la tour
je suis obligé de la prendre parce que
j'ai donné un peu le centre en jouant en
cavalier français 3 lorsque le flakka
est prend C3 je perds un tempo et en
plus je ramène les pions vers le centre
le riz donc à terme les blancs
réussissent et 4 donc il fallait aller
au bout des choses si je prends sa
décision là et tourbé un je donne ma
tour mais à la fin je gagne le foot
casse blanche avec ces cases blanches
très ouvertes voilà avec mon fou qui
pourra sans doute rayonner en Détroit
voilà c'est ouvert franchement on le
voit et la pression de la dame sur le
pion B7 donc c'est un coup piquant en
fait de manière masque tourbée
le totalement et en fait si ce qui est
magnifique c'est que non ça préparation
il l'encourage à faire des coups qui
sont totalement logiques et a attendu
donc c'est les meilleurs coups même mais
il a des idées derrière la tête et
l'avantage c'est qu'il est préparé sur
ces idées précisément
un énorme avantage comme tu le dis le
riz une heure dans la tronche Daniel
guéri qui a aussi la réputation d'être
très bien préparée
est connu aussi d'ailleurs sur ce sujet
là
gros duel de de joueurs qui qui bossent
les échecs comme des dingues et en fait
pour l'instant ça a tourné à l'avantage
des pièces blanches ce qui n'est pas à
nouveau avec les noirs on essaie
d'égaliser et on prend l'avantage si
l'adversaire déconne avec les Blancs on
joue pour essayer de prendre l'avantage
directement franchement donc tour B8
d'un B3 regardez cet esprit
d'initiative à chaque coup ou piquant
et la prise de décision je pensais
peut-être que anis grill a joué 7
je vais pas aller en je vais me faire
enfermer mon fou non je vais pas lancer
l'échange des pièces puisque j'ai plus
de matériel
ok pourquoi pas Dame des 5 c'est la
problématique du coup et il avait prévu
F4 et comme ça si on échange les dames
petite finale avec davantage matériel
BIM Damme cat
bon ça devait être prévu quand même
reproposition des changes de dames
et
je garde les dames je garde mon gros
centre
et j'ai aussi mon gros au fou qui va
arriver
Aniche guéri de cette séquence de
proposition d'échange de dames avec
l'avantage matériel l'objectif c'est
qu'il arrive ici avec dama 3 et bam hop
contre le jeu
vous voyez exactement ce que les joueurs
font à haut niveau c'est des coups
piquants des coups piquants des coups
contrecoup piquant à nouveau Fatou avec
ce damechec
cavalier 7 parce qu'on n'a pas envie
d'être des roquets on n'a pas envie de
ramener la dame en recettes et dames ces
deux pour défendre
cavalier
dame c'est 3 ou
[Musique]
ouais et c'est chaud dans ces trois
potentiellement ces quatre jouets alors
sur pas mal de coups là c'est chaud là
franchement c'est hyper chaud parce que
on peut jouer kb4 on peut jouer damso3
on peut jouer caresser 3
ces trois c'était pas bien on a presque
envie de jouer ça ça semble être assez
logique Fatou pour avoir du du comment
dirais-je
de l'avantage de l'avantage matériel
valorisé en finale
ok mais
avoir parce qu'en fait tu as une qualité
de main quand même un pion
donc
cavalier bizarre peut-être ici alors ça
serait quoi on peut regarder quand même
3 donc dame prend j'ai pas trop le choix
cavalier prend
il attaque à deux donc c'est posé une
question tout de suite exactement et je
t'avouerai Fatou que je n'avais pas vu
je n'avais pas vu que j'ai attaqué à
deux avec j'étais content d'échanger les
dames et j'étais
j'avais hyper peur pour mon cavalier
donc j'étais en train de me dire je vais
me casser par là ou par là et j'ai même
pas vu que je pouvais me casser par là
bim BIM voilà quelque chose comme ça
c'était intéressant quand même pour pour
les Noirs cette suite je
sais en fait si tu veux j'aime bien dire
la méthode anti-jeux enfin tout quand
j'ai de l'avantage matériel j'essaie de
mettre en place un petit jeu où je
commence à échanger toutes les pièces
mais pas vraiment toutes les pièces ce
que je vois certains joueurs amateurs
qui abusent de cette règle de l'antijeux
de l'échange des pièces Fatou et ils
échangent leurs bonnes pièces contre des
pièces de l'adversaire qui sont pas très
bonnes
[Musique]
la dame elle est dangereuse mon roi il a
chaud donc là dame c'est trois je fais
ça pas couillon
et roi des deux sur
Rouen parce que roi des deux c'est
évidemment pas possible donc ça doit
être un
pour moi c'est la même chose je crois D1
alors peut-être pas
en fait j'allais te croquer en C2 je
pense que les noirs sont un peu mieux
mais est-ce que je peux obtenir plus
est-ce que plus te saouler ces dames des
deux excuse-moi Dame des deux sur dame
C3 même chose dame C3 Dame des deux bah
je peux prendre un n'importe quel moment
mais je peux aussi jouer la main faut
voir mais en tout cas je suis content la
méthode anti jeune fonctionne
donc je suis je suis très étonné je
comprends pas la décision de Dany Jerry
il a peut-être jugé que c'était
c'était une position très
amusante parce que je pense pas que les
Noirs soient moins bien quand même
il y a un pion plus un joli fou mais les
tours ce sera activé et j'aurais plus de
danger sur mon roi
j'échange enfin tout parce que j'ai peur
quand même de me faire carotter avec mon
avantage matériel avec mon roi un peu
faible donc l'échange de dames me permet
de sécuriser mon roi c'est pour ça que
je fais ça c'est ça dans mon objectif
cavalier ces trois c'est tendu
très très tendu là
c'est dangereux franchement et du coup
avant de Forest il joue il joue que
c'est 5 c'est excellent pour les cases
blancs toujours pas aïe
et j'ai pas le droit de faire dame prend
à deux parce qu'il y a mon pote le
cahier C3 en l'air et franchement est-ce
que j'ai le droit de faire cavalier
prend un deux je crois pas regardez
typiquement vous souvenez je venais de
proposer l'histoire d'échanger les dames
j'ai hyper peur de cavalier prend un
deux ici
cavalier prend à deux je sais pas mais
va m'arriver des bricoles c'est pas
comment enfin tous mais je trouve ça
trop risqué peut-être fou B5 d'ailleurs
pour essayer de roquer et sur ces 6
dames 4
j'ai peur en fait dans cette position
avec mes pièces complètement ouais
je trouve que qu'il a pas joué le jeu et
Aniche alors Aniche il a un peu snobé je
trouve grande forêt parce qu'il lui dit
allez vas-y je fais baisser je fais ce
que je veux dans la position et on était
arrivé là
et regardez comment il a joué avant le
reste je mets mon roi à l'abri c'est
l'urgence B prend C5 j'ouvre les
colonnes mais je constate caniche guéri
il a pas sécurisé son roi donc là il a
chaud ça commence à il commence à avoir
des idées de kfg5
petit rock jouet pour sécuriser le roi
ça va être chaud vous voyez comme moi la
jauge donc c'est beaucoup plus facile de
m'exprimer ici
on a un avantage matériel très important
avec les Noirs l'ordinateur préfère les
blancs est-ce que tu peux nous dire
pourquoi
la compensation l'activité
de 11 personnes voilà shotari alors
est-ce que tu le connais shotari Fatou
non non
à tous et bonjour à ceux qu'on a comme
effectivement le chat ça c'est vite et
on parle beaucoup bonjour bienvenue à
tous
mais à chaque ça a beaucoup de sens
alors nous on n'a pas leur dit un
missourou mais à chaque c'est un des
coups candidats mais c'est Fatou qui va
nous dire ce qu'elle en pense
non mais on a vu les Noirs
cette qualité et
rentrer chez les Blancs comme ça
mais les Blancs n'ont rien à faire parce
que alors qu'elles sont dirigés vers le
roi donc le fou la dame vous voyez les
directions le cavalier pareil en deux
coups il est dessus et le petit pion h
donc H5 sa façon c'est toujours le même
le même délire je te rende dedans j'ai
envie de tu vois ton beau petit
squelette parfait moi je viens et j'ai
envie de dire exactement on a vraiment
un gros vœu alors le coup que j'avais
envie de jouer alors maintenant dans le
chat on m'a dit que c'était à Shang le
coup mitsouru moi le coup un peu basique
que j'avais envie de faire ici c'est
qu'elle va les G5 j'étais en train de
calculer G6 à 5 voilà ce que j'avais
envie de faire le problème
voilà exactement et c'est plus précis
pourquoi parce que sur cavalier G5 j'ai
6 à 5
je pense qu'à d'un B2 autour B2 dans
cette position et on va essayer de
déglinguer madame de La de la diago
parce que là il y a grosse menace de
Hong Kong
B2 ou dame B2 quelque chose comme ça
comment je peux changer les pièces là il
vient aux gens d'échanger les dames même
là c'est pas si évident que ça
ça me laisse un petit peu de temps même
peut-être un petit haschiste
me fait mal c'est une blague évidemment
pour le chat vous l'aurez compris c'est
une des idées d'achats d'ailleurs on l'a
pas dit mais l'idée de h1 excusez-moi
c'est h.g.h.g Dame prend G6 le pion F7
est cloué et oui la tactique toujours la
tactique attention on regarde bien
toujours les aliments parce que alors là
c'est le coup du pigeon celui qui fait
H6 vraiment c'est pas beau même d'y
penser c'est pas beau mais ça arrive à
tout le monde vous êtes indulgent dans
le chat c'est tout ce que tu disais ça
pour le chat ah bah évidemment
évidemment c'est ce qu'on appelle une
erreur pédagogique du coup c'est quoi
évidemment merci de me soutenir dans
dans ce dans ce coup un peu triste alors
comment je fais ici il y a sûrement une
réfute on voit un gros avantage non et
j'arrive pas à trouver je rage là avec
les Noirs comment j'éteins l'action de
mon adversaire d'un B2
comment je fais pour B2 quand j'ai envie
de choix l'idée mais j'arrive pas à la
mettre en place
comment je fais c'est tour B2 ou d'un B2
en fait il va jouer Dame des trois pour
regarder les dames
et continuer sur la menace donc je
cherche comment je peux faire alors pour
B2
D3
quand bouge les pièces c'est plus facile
aux échecs bon c'est un calcul de
3 demi coups c'est quand même
réalisable et à tourbé 6 couilles mais
bon tu sais ma méthode antijeux elle est
infaillible là c'est horrible quoi avec
les Blancs ça va pas du tout du coup je
peux vous garantir que vendre forest ne
jouera pas
je pense pas je pense qu'il va réfléchir
il va trouver le très précis à chaque
c'est comme pas la même un coup oui je
pense bon peut-être ça marche aussi ton
tour B6
je trouve ça plus tendre je trouve ça
plus tendre vraiment je sais pas encore
comment je vais avoir mais
tu me laisses maintenant des
perspectives d'attaque peut-être pour
c'est un pour dégager ton cavalier là
il y aurait peut-être ouais c'est pas
mal tour c'est est-ce que c'est pas mal
ouais en tout cas c'est intéressant
aussi
c'est que pour que la dame reste à la il
faut qu'elle reste sur sa diagonale et
elle a pas elle a pas 10000 cases une
fois que notamment aussi je voudrais
virer le cavalier pour amener ma dame à
la fête ou comment je peux couper la
tour de couvitch en tout cas on voit
très clairement que tour B2 en fait dans
le registre ça existe de défendre une
position mais le meilleur registre pour
défendre une position c'est la
contre-attaque très clairement donc pour
B2 force Dame des trois si on veut
rester sur la fête du roi cavalier 2
c'est réglé je pense qu'on voit tous on
va pas s'étendre là dessus par contre on
va voir les différences H5
tour B2 et à chaque tour B2 quelle est
la différence il y a une grosse
différence je pense que c'est d'un F5 la
grosse différence Fatou c'est ce que
d'expliquer si tu restes sur la
diagonale et là j'insiste un pas encore
été fait donc ça te permet de rester
dans cette attaque on peut pas bien joué
connecté très très bien oui la grosse
différence quand même du H5 très précis
donner donc dans le chat donner par
notre pote l'ordinateur c'est bien de le
dire quand vous avez le droit de
regarder avec l'ordinateur si vous
voulez essayer de regarder quand même
majoritairement par vous-même vous
regardez par vous-même et après
éventuellement si vous avez un souci de
compréhension vous regardez à l'ordi et
souvent ça marche mieux
plutôt regarder l'ordinateur si c'est
pour demander une explication
potentielle comme là on peut essayer
d'expliquer justement en plus d'ailleurs
et là cavalier 2 c'est peut-être juste
roi h
bon c'est plus plus logique avec l'idée
cavalier 5 et on est on est sûrement
très bien donc du coup ben à chaque
qu'est-ce qu'on joue avec
avec les noirs on n'a pas encore cette
position à l'écran vente Forest en train
de il a vraiment du temps 1h20 contre 33
minutes il va essayer de trouver la
meilleure suite pour mettre mal à l'aise
à Nice guéri valoriser sa position et le
même mal à l'aise au temps aussi Fatou
hein
énormément sur le temps et
il faut
justement de jouer très très vite parce
que ils ont pas être des joueurs
exceptionnels
quand on manque de temps forcément on
peut on peut plus facilement gaffer
après il y a gaffe et AGA gaffe nounou
on peut gâter on peut donner des pièces
eux ils vont faire une une petite erreur
stratégique positionnelle mais c'est
qu'il voit une gaffe à ce niveau là non
mais complètement
il faut aussi mettre la pression au
temps les joueurs sous pression sont
quand même remarquables on l'a vu au
cheval du monde de Blitz et de rapide
néanmoins on a vu aussi même Carcen
gaffe au championnat du monde de rapides
contre artemiev on se souvient tous de
la pièce en cours randoms contre
Nakamura il a pris une attaque double en
un coup assez ridicule vu le niveau de
maîtrise de Carlsen et sa constance en
règle générale
ce qui montre que n'importe quel joueur
d'échec est faible sous pression du
temps même s'il reste quand même très
fort même sous pression du temps
normalement général il ne gaz pas en
tout cas là il faut être précis pour
pour rendre Forex
peut-être le tour B6 regardez pour
ramener du monde en défense je faire G6
ou tourachis ça a l'air bien l'idée de
te proposer par oui tout à l'heure parti
hyper intéressante en tout cas à suivre
aujourd'hui tu aimes bien choisi enfin
tout et elle est top cette partie merci
on va vers les autres joueurs il nous
reste quelques quelques échiquiers après
on fera une petite pause on va regarder
vite fait tous les étiquettes il faut
continuer le petit tour ouais le petit
tour avec
Henri char rapporte assez assez
tranquille contre dingueren apparemment
là bien baissé quand on est arrivé là il
venait d'avoir F5 de
quand même pas grand grand-chose mais il
voulait ouvrir les cases blanches pour
son four il y a eu F3 pas apprécié du
tout par l'ordinateur
qu'est-ce qui fallait jouer prises F5
peut-être mais c'est risqué d'ouvrir la
paire de fouger 2 vous voyez là l'astuce
de Digne il a un fou distinctif c'est le
seul à avoir le footclasse blanche il
ouvre
il y avait cavalier 5 qui était à
disposition
ça faisait peur ce cavalier 5 en
allemand ça donne les pas envie parce
que il a dû voir foumpion prend
cavalier B6 ça faisait très peur
puisqu'on n'a pas on n'a pas cavalier C4
je pense qu'il n'a pas voulu cette
variante pour cela
donc il a joué le légitime F3
ça ne choque pas F3 est-ce que c'était
le quoi attendu par l'ordinateur non il
y avait cavalier G3 dispositions avec
sur F4 cavalier F5
je vais être obligé de prendre ce
foulard
c'est un peu décevant quoi parce que
c'est quoi pour le moment il fait rien
par défaut
donc est-ce qu'on a envie d'aller le
chercher dans l'autre côté en F il fait
rien non plus
on fait pression sur le pion arrière sur
colonne Somi ouvert comme on a vu tout à
l'heure il y aura des thèmes redondants
entre les parties pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas après sur kg 3 il pouvait aussi
prendre en E4 et puis avoir un gros
centre donc c'était pas simple c'est
pour ça je pense que Richard apporte a
joué le coup F3 avec l'idée je reprends
le cadre du pion pour contrôler ton
centre et pas trop ouvrir les cases
blanches
c'est comme ça que tu as dû voir
c'est normal j'ai l'impression
j'ai l'impression salut Olito salut à
tous ceux qui nous rejoignent du coup F3
pourquoi c'est mauvais je ne sais pas
honnêtement je ne sais pas eux prend F5
c'était très bizarre c'était le coup que
vous voulez leur dire visiblement on
voit que la jauge n'a pas n'a pas bougé
faut prendre deux
et là il fallait jouer tourgé peut-être
à l'initiative
pour mettre la pression ou tour H2 c'est
bizarre pour j'ai un fouet fin qu'est-ce
qui se passe
je suis obligé de garder la pression ici
donc
je comprends Grisha rapporte il a pas eu
envie de jouer ça parce que certes il y
a d'initiative à tout mais c'est le
squelette le pion le plus dégueulasse
possible c'est pour ça que du duo de ces
2740 il a pas plus trouvé cette suite
déjà faut un petit calcul on est à 5
demi coup on Richard apporte qui peut
calculer 20 demi coupes sans problème et
quasiment instantanément bon j'exagère
un peu mais pas tant que ça en fait en
tout cas il a des une puissance
calculatoire très importante
et là on n'a pas petit rock je pense que
l'ordi lui voit tout il calcule ça il
faut prendre un 6 ce serait bien quand
même d'avoir petit rock parce que j'ai
besoin de protéger ça il y a la case des
5 il y a le problème en général
comment je défends j'ai il est possible
que
d'y mettre la tour exactement c'est
c'est dur et comme digne il annonce tu
peux pas jouer ça Marie porte il a dû
regarder quelques secondes cette
position en disant ah j'ai un squelette
dégueulasse mais l'ordinateur c'est une
supercalculette il analyse cette
position et il voit
l'opportunité de poser des problèmes
concrets à l'adversaire même s'il a une
structure dégueu sur le long terme voilà
c'est joli c'est joli et merci en tout
cas pour le suivi on a mis Tsuru qui
nous dit que H5 a été joué c'est vrai
qu'on a toujours la cam Danish à l'écran
mais c'est bien pour l'instant c'est la
partie la plus intéressante je trouve en
terme de créativité avec une belle prépa
donc c'est pas un mal d'avoir la cam on
revient
exactement
c'est vrai c'est vrai on va finir notre
tour des stats donc il y a eu F3 ça
reste solide c'est à peu près égal cette
position
faiblesse côté des Noirs quand même mais
ils ont le fou donc sur le long terme ça
peut faire mal
du coup qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
autrement on va voir on continue notre
tour des échiquiers avec une partie un
peu plus terne mais si on a beaucoup
étudié les pions isolés dans les
différentes parties de ce tata style là
vous avez une des structures les plus
classiques aux échecs avec les pions
pendant puis on pendant
alors c'est bien mais plus les pièces
s'échangent plus cette chambre pendant
peuvent devenir fragile dans les finales
c'est la raison pour laquelle des fois
comme dans un pion isolé on peut avoir
des décades des fois on peut avoir des
C4 aussi pour travailler sur les cases
alors comment on travaillerait peut-être
par là par là par là par là bon pour
faire tout ce que je dis c'est pas si
facile mais en tout cas on reconnaît la
structure des pions pendant ici sont
deux pions côte à côte qui sont sur des
colonnes semi-ouvertes et qui sont mous
c'est un petit stylo de deux pions qui
n'a pas de soutien de pion le riz voilà
on vient de regarder van forest on a
passé peut-être dessus c'est une des
parties qui a l'air d'être les plus
excitantes et c'est vrai que là notre
excitation retombe un petit peu en
regardant cette partie entre Google et à
rognan qui promet d'être plus modeste
après c'est très technique peut-être que
toi professeur d'ailleurs tu préfères ce
genre de petite position ça correspond
bien à ton style de serrure voilà
tu aimes bien les trucs un peu plus
plan-plan je pense en fait tu aimes bien
regarder ventes forest mais tu préfères
jouer comme comme à rognon quoi voilà
si je puis me permettre
Cyril qui en rajoute une couche j'avais
pas vu ta remarque Cyril mais c'est très
bonne remarque les parties d'un oignon
sont très terne dans ce tournoi et bim
ça c'est gratuit voilà
il prend plus de sécurité qu'avant voilà
il y a tout de la jeune génération qui
est très calculéatoire
il joue un bouqueth qui est capable de
s'envoyer en l'air il a les Noirs il a
l'air quand même d'avoir un tandem
cavalier assez adapté dans cette
position pousser le pion a peut-être
avec un petit A4 à un moment pour fixer
les pions à 3 et B2 et travailler sur le
pion B2 elle faut pourra venir en C3
allez je vous je dirais nul non c'est
dans cette partie je passe pas trop de
temps Laurie et je passe directement
chez parram qui a fait une énorme partie
hier mais qui a bénéficié quand même
d'un
d'un petit pragnananda par rapport à
d'habitude et là c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué très déséquilibré cette
position
il joue l'acrobate herigasi donc mon
partenaire de club
c'était une défense grandefeld si ça
vous intéresse et la position est très
déséquilibrée une perte de fou Laurie
pour les Noirs mais en compensation des
belles pièces et blanc et un pion passé
hyper dangereux un pion passé l'éléphant
dans un coup quoi le pion passé le pion
qui a atteint la sixième rangée il prend
de la valeur si vous voulez il est hyper
dangereux
dans le 3 bizarre pas à quoi ça sert
ok on aimerait bien je sais pas faire
peut-être de la F4 fois F6 et changer ce
foulard déjà et après travailler le roi
et en plus valorisation là avec les
Noirs peut-être falloir un moment je
vais fouder 7 et puis
attention pour l'instant la dame est en
l'air donc je sais pas où mettre madame
ok il peut se passer encore beaucoup de
choses on a fait un
très joli tour des stades
rien alors
je crois franchement on a passé plus de
temps comme d'habitude vous savez sur
sur Magnus qui joue Prague sur Kemer un
petit peu parce que c'est le chouchou de
Laurie sur adossa Tora qui est en tête
et qui mène demain de mettre ce tournoi
et on verra Guiri qui en embuscade qui
peut à nouveau être le pluie d'or de
cette édition du tata style et Van
forest qui lui a mis une grosse prépa
quoi
donc du coup
on va pas tarder à faire à faire la
pause tout simplement Lorie
on entend les notifs
en plus je pense que c'est mes notifs
d'ailleurs professionnel tu fais bien de
me le dire je pense en tout cas
donc on va bien voir en maîtrise pas on
maîtrise pas forcément le moment où on
va être en pause j'ai envoyé un petit un
petit message le temps qu'on nous
réponde on peut aller faire un petit
coucou à Magnus qu'on n'a pas vu depuis
longtemps
et
ben ça va être la souffrance je crois
pour pour notre petit Prague aujourd'hui
aussi avec un petit plus pour
je pense que on le ressent tous une très
belle paire de cavaliers dans une
structure fixée
donc les fous vont moins s'exprimer le
centre Descartes des 5 va tenir pendant
très très longtemps
on a un très bel avant-poste en E5 bien
sûr on peut donner notre fou mais alors
on fera le temps cavalier et une
amélioration des pièces
là
puis même mon rock il est pas stable
on peut regarder comment est intervenu
cette position mais ce qui est marrant
c'est que c'est les noirs on a pensé à
un moment qui a les requis rapidement ou
pas les blancs et finalement les blancs
on roquet et malgré la poussée hache
donc il a décidé lui-même de bloquer la
position avec le H5 de bloquer les pions
alors on était là cette dame des deux ou
Manu ça est bloqué le petit
jouet et là la compréhension des
structures va faire le reste le petit
achat de Magnus qui n'a pas du tout
l'intention d'attaquer le roi
et pour travailler sur les cases
blanches d'ailleurs en cas de petit rock
il y a quand même un match en Hachette
qui pourrait traîner avec une batterie
fou dame voilà je ferai un truc comme ça
et je peux avoir un match sur rachète
quand même il y a un petit peu d'attaque
mais surtout il veut valoriser cette
pièce sous le câble monstrueux
et là direct il a vu une opportunité à
ça incroyable dans cette structure fixe
il a dit ma paire de cavaliers
maintenant elle est bonne et je vais
vous prendre des 5 on voit que la jauge
n'a pas aimé mais quand on sait que
Magnus Carlson est hyper technique là la
partie qui est partie qui allait être
une partie plutôt d'attaque le riz ça
devient plutôt un jeu positionnel ou
Magnus va torturer Prague voilà il veut
le torturer l'autre décision c'était
peut-être de jouer cavalier prend des
cinq aussi ça avait ça avait du sens bon
on a aussi le temps on pouvait jouer des
coups comme petit rock peut-être et
travailler mais la définit cette
position avec potiron
aussi ça a été joué pour défendre
pour un très facile et oui toutes les
pièces sont bonnes petits rock
maintenant je sais pas comment avancer
le riz je peux améliorer mes pièces et
de faire du petit jeu ou alors je peux
je peux attaquer de façon bouchère
on maîtrise bien la position faut pas
ouvrir les case noire avec le fou passe
là bon en même temps si on fait F4 si on
prend on peut prendre de Notre-Dame
après juste un petit truc sur F4 qui est
très très intéressant puis on prend d'un
point il y a dame j'ai 5 je crois
j'aimerais c'est possible ne pas
échanger les dames Laurie parce que le
roi noir est quand même plus affaibli
donc je vais attendre un petit peu
peut-être qu'il faut préparer un petit
peu plus
jouer des coups juste comme ça pour deux
tours mon adversaire il est bien fixé le
petit Prague donc j'ai pas envie de
m'exciter tout de suite
ce qui est intéressant c'est le cavalier
qui est bien placé
par un pion
et sur l'échange on est le premier
content non plus
et du coup je peux aussi travailler donc
mes tours alors on sait
l'amélioration de cavaliers A4 cavaliers
C5 le travail aussi avec cette dame qui
est maintenant est un peu modeste Dame
des reins ou d'un de ces deux j'en sais
rien je passe à la dame MP3 j'ai envie
de faire ce qu'on appelle de
l'amélioration lente pour valoriser mon
avantage Lorie
c'est ça tu as raison
tranquillement quand on a un avantage
souvent aussi au niveau débutant
on panique un peu et le nombre de
parties gagnantes qui sont alignés c'est
toujours exactement
alors du coup on a disparu
on a disparu mais on est revenu
on a disparu puis on est revenu écoute
ce que je te propose Lorie ben tant que
là on a pas de nouvelles de notre région
on n'a pas de nouvelles chez lamette à
l'écran la régie pour que pour que tu la
vois
et ce qui a été sur mon autre écran du
coup
Abdou après je vous promets
la pause on va retourner voir avant de
Forest puisque vous en parlez dans le
chat donc là
on a Wesley sceaux qui
travaillent pas d'accord on a un message
que je n'ai pas vu alors et à l'instant
pourquoi moi je l'ai pas
ça je ne sais pas
ok ok
donc du coup on va bientôt partir en
pause sans vous le dit ok j'ai pas vu le
message
j'aurais peut-être prochainement donc là
il se passe rien c'est même Abdou qui
travaille un peu plus mais je vous
pronostique une petite nulle pour cette
partie entre d'où ça t'auras et West
Esso qui n'a pas réussi à poser de
problème
on peut donc aller voir la partie qui
vous excite dans le chat et vous avez
bien raison puisque malheureusement
c'est en train de mal tourner pour
Aniche lyrics
et maintenant j'ai trois
il n'y a plus les histoires de tout à
l'heure avec l'échange de dames il n'y a
plus les tours B2 là la grosse menace ça
a changé 6 et kubitch tu vas être bon
pour nous jouer ton tour B6 mais sans
doute que ça ne marche pas on voit que
la jauge c'est enflammée on rappelle que
la menace des blancs c'est maintenant de
jouer ashong G6 suivi de dames Tran G6
grâce au fou ces cartes c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que
Van fofu là il vient de protéger son fou
voilà
oui en fait les messages juste pour ils
apparaissent au dessus
si je ne m'abuse
donc on a la réponse mais au-dessus des
messages
ok je vois pas c'est pas très grave mais
en tout cas je pense que c'est du coup
c'est a priori quand tu veux la poser
pour nous
là je sais pas si elle les voit
bien
on va voir en tout cas si
je pense qu'on est parti c'est bon ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes de retour pas tout pour le
dénouement de cette avant dernière ronde
enfin dénouement en tout cas ça commence
à être bien avancé l'histoire surtout
sur une partie la partie qui est la plus
belle avec une heure d'avant à la
pendule on va aller directement sur
l'échiquier et vous le voyez à l'écran
de vente forest contre guéri
préparation de vente forest sans doute
ou bluff je sais pas en tout cas moi
j'aurais échangé les drames comme je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure et
en tout cas j'aurais peut-être pas gagné
la partie bien sûr à Nice guéri c'est un
des grands comptes du jeu d'échec mais
je ne me serais pas fait mater et là on
est dans les perspectives qui avaient
indiqué de Covic il y a de cela
peut-être une heure Fatou et il y a une
défense de rangée qui se met en place
donc comment va continuer on sait que la
jauge est très à l'avantage des blancs
il va falloir qu'on se creuse la tête
enfin tout pour pour gagner cette partie
au moins trouver la ressource parce que
ça a l'air de tenir l'histoire au
premier abord donc qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
[Musique]
on avait vu
et salut à tous ceux qui nous ont
rejoints
j'ai une
méchanceté là j'ai une méchanceté j'ai
des idées avec des trucs comme ça là
mais dépenser 5 non il y a peut-être
d'un Français 5 tout simplement j'avais
envie de faire cavalier première F7
tours
maintenant il veut pas prendre donc des
Français 5 à 6 d'un Français 5 ça
attaque mon cavalier
ce que j'attaque aussi le cavalier alors
on va réfléchir on n'est pas loin de
quelque chose là
peut-être en plus ça sent le A3 cette
position je sais pas pourquoi ce que
vous sentez comme moi un feeling de A3
là je sais pas pourquoi mais ça pourrait
ça pourrait le petit à trois il y a
plusieurs coups candidats je regarde les
coups très concrets j'ai même envie de
faire
F7 le registre tactique est de sortie
l'ordinateur nous indique un plus trois
il y a une raison très concrète à cela
alors comment on peut faire pour
c'est la dame qui tient tout elle tient
Sarah elle tient ça
peut-être il y avait mon histoire de
thoursin on si j'aime bien ce genre de
coup parce que ma tour elle sert à rien
c'est pas ridicule non plus
il va falloir
lorsque la question si on voit la jauge
on se demande s'il y a pas une attaque
une attaque sur le roi nos pièces sont
placées pour mais est-ce que dit Kévin
aussi peut-être une boutique
[Musique]
des Français
d'apprendre peut-être cavalier prend F7
et maintenant d'un point C3
donc alors des Français 5 mon idée
c'est déjà d'activer ma dame sur des
thèmes comme la 8e rangée
j'attaque la tour en plus donc c'est à
moitié gratos l'histoire je vérifie
quand même des Français 5 dames français
5 ça attaque mon cavalier
bien sûr j'attaque aussi le cavalier
adverse donc j'ai pensé à cavalier
comme ça je pourrais me refaire une
qualité
mesdam prend ces trois c'est intéressant
mais il y a peut-être encore mieux je
sais pas j'essaie de
tout de tout regarder
l'ordinateur donc ouais non mais c'est
logique de celle-ci qu'on avait proposé
dans la vente de covid tout à l'heure
des Français 5 j'aime bien aussi enfin
c'est les cours en tout cas candidat
entre ça et ça et les deux ont le même
objectif c'est désossé le cavalier qui
tient la position en fait c'est vrai que
sur tout ça ce qui est un peu malheureux
c'est que j'ai pas de bonne case pour le
cavalier alors pour séance qui
m'ennuyait un petit peu c'est c'est
prendre des quatre
bon apparemment c'est prendre des cartes
c'est pas un problème alors tourcien on
voit la chose a quand même c'est
vraiment le coup qui est qui est
apparemment c'est ça donc pour C1
oui c'est prendre des cartes c'est
peut-être pas le coup de génie
sur ces points des cartes il y a pas de
cavalier de j'ai le droit de faire des
quatre
attention à la ça commence à
vraiment menacer parce qu'attention vous
voyez dame prend des 4 il y a la cage G7
et je peux faire un schiste il y a pas
F6 hein
un tour séance c'est vraiment logique
maintenant j'aimerais bien trouver le
coup de défense à glaît noir j'aimerais
bien éviter les cavaliers B5 avec
cavaliers mais est-ce que j'ai le choix
dans ce cas là parce que
cavalier V5 et cavalier ça donne une
réponse vraiment pas envie et on
conserve mes idées de dépenser 5 en plus
avec ce coup-là donc bon
[Musique]
dans le chat ne mettez pas les coudes
proposés juste
franchement de toute façon ça a l'air
des Français 5 tours et 6 a été proposé
ouais
ok ça va peut-être ok c'était peut-être
intéressant
même si je prends bon vous savez c'est
des perspectives comme à la dame
il est question aussi de A3
ça donnait envie aussi mais bon la dame
en BK
si on fait à 3 qui paraît intéressant
pour faire bouger la dame on a plus ce
tour c'est un
[Musique]
c'est pas un coup très compliqué pour
Jordan van ferest pourquoi parce que
c'est la pièce qui joue le moins c'est
la pièce la plus débile de sa position
et le cavalier C3 c'est une des pièces
les plus gênantes donc pour c'est il va
falloir que j'ai un coup de cavalier
allez cavaliers
A4 parce qu'il y aura encore de cavalier
B2
ça commence à être très chaud mes pièces
sont vraiment très bien passé
mais il y a encore un peu de boulot pour
terminer alors même si on voit que la
jauge
ces gros avantages il y a un petit peu
de calcul déjà vous voyez que d'ailleurs
je leur donne une grande forêt ne joue
pas à toute berzingue et
oui ici je dois chercher la manière de
finir et j'ai pas le droit de me gourer
faites juste des Français 5 ans ça a
l'air logique pour ouvrir les pièces on
va voir mais
ça conserve vraiment l'avantage ça doit
être le coup normal
comment y reprendre bah pas de la dame
parce que Fatou il y a le rayon laser
avec voilà
donc ça paraît très difficile attention
on en a parlé les alignements dans les
tactiques c'est important exactement
faut se méfier tout à fait tout à fait
donc là on voit qu'on est quand même en
difficulté
donc
du coup cavalier prononcer 5 je pense
que c'est logique
et là faut trouver le coup de grâce
et je regarde des coups franchement ça
peut ça pourrait faire la différence
suivi de Dame des 8
c'est très très dangereux pour
c'est les lignes comme ça qui va falloir
calculer en tout cas faut prendre cette
peut-être
tour.f7
j'avais pas envie de donner mon coeur va
bien je veux le garder ce cavalier il me
paraît très fort pour lattaque et j'ai
envie de jouer dame D8 une des idées que
j'ai c'est sur moi G7 faire H6 pour
gagner la tour entière et si la tour
vend F8 je joue dame E7 ou dame C7
j'attaque ça j'attaque ça
j'étais content j'ai l'impression enfin
tout c'était maths moi cette position
et je vois que l'ordi il me donne un 3
donc il dit que je fais pas trop
n'importe quoi mais je m'attendais à ce
qu'ils me disent plus mille
non mais je sais toujours pas pourquoi
franchement de voir ça de loin à la
place d'Aniche gueri ben je suis en
pleurs quoi après les mecs ont de la
ressource mais la niche il a 12 minutes
en tout cas ça a l'air d'être
pas mal ce genre de variante
on avait prévu plutôt d'aller voir Abdou
et manus carlossen mais là la partie van
forest guéri vole la vedette au
meilleur joueur pour le moment en tout
cas dans son noir encore que guéri est
très très bien placé il faut pas
l'oublier les outsider
number one de Abdou
dans ce dans ce tour là
j'ai fait une petite blague un moment
mais bon
j'ai vu la réplique de quoi
je pensais que c'était un coup de tour
mais je savais pas où l'idée
[Musique]
en se disant on va mater après parce
qu'il y a un petit un petit cavalier
échec qui traîne
et une petite découverte sur la dame
mais tenter de prendre du coin H7
franchement déjà tu as l'impression
d'être quasiment plié
ça fait mal on a presque plus d'échec
puis il y a des noces quoi
en tout cas ça devrait tourner autour de
ça
très très compliqué à cette position
incroyable
on est d'accord que il y a plus de gains
donc peut-être est-ce que j'ai le droit
à F2 il y a deux croix à regarder des
trois ça me fait pas trop peur
par contre Dame des deux ça faut hyper
les jetons
ouais ça peut être hyper chaud
reprend ce que je peux me cacher
c'est pas sûr
waouh ça va être compliqué
c'est jouer et je pense que c'est bien
joué
ah non il n'a pas joué
alors on va regarder maintenant que ça a
été joué il a joué des Français 5
ok mais c'est un petit peu la même ligne
peut-être que ce qu'on a vu là alors on
va voir juste pour une fois petit
entorse au règlement je vais voir les
variantes donc c'était bien tourcé un
alors c'était bien pour c'est un comme
on a dit
ça va être édit dans le chat de toute
façon cavalier à 4 meilleures lignes
comme ça il y a des cavaliers B2 ça
ressemble logique des Français 5
meilleurs coups pas forcément l'ordi
trouver un coin de trouvable
trouve un soin de toi belle formule
dans le 4
par contre c'était rigolo parce que
tu as plus de sens avec les passer par
là juste pour vous expliquer un petit
peu les les coups d'ordi mais ok donc
dans le cadre peut-être avec tout
reprendre qui existe toujours donc c'est
toujours difficile ok
des français c'était quand même assez
normal on va revenir dans les idées de
français 5 et on a les effets de
meilleur cours tours
et là il fallait voir de loin tour
reprend F2 qui était introuvable de loin
enfin si c'est trouvable mais c'était
quand même très très dur
ce que c'est un coup oui il y avait
d'autres coups comme tout F5 qui était
peut-être pas mal aussi bon du coup
c'est extrêmement compliqué je leur
donne votre forêt ça doit être dépenser
5 directement
voilà avec les mêmes thèmes de cavalier
F7 et compagnie
il ouvre la dame si vous voulez pour
travailler sur le pion F7
et à tempo pour C6
et voilà et là il y a encore du travail
il y a encore du travail pas tout c'est
pas si simple de gagner cette position
c'est sûr
[Musique]
on aime encore le classement des pièces
blanc
avec toi à jouer dans ma carte ça paraît
pas être dans l'esprit de la position
après hummet tu l'avais peut-être tu
l'avais peut-être vu mais bon je peux
trouver mais en tout cas un niche tour
C6 il sait qu'il est sous pression
mais on dit qu'à haut niveau je trouvais
des défenses c'est un côté un petit peu
économique parce que tu es obligé
quasiment enfin tout de trouver le seul
coup pour pour survivre et du coup c'est
ce qui est en train de se passer il a
réussi à faire le taf
est-ce qu'on va voir
juste la petite histoire je voulais
enlever ça je peux pas l'enlever ce truc
là
voilà ça y est j'ai réussi à performance
incroyable pour voir s'il y avait les
résultats mais ce n'est toujours pas
fini chez So et abusa torov juste petit
détour vers cette partie moins
palpitante et j'ai l'impression qu'on
aura le droit prochainement à une petite
nuit là
je pense Fatou hier on a eu un petit
stream avec Laurent toi tu es venu pour
un pour un stream sur la longueur sans
doute
c'est que le stream de mercredi avec
stouf au bout de 2h
terrible j'en ai profité je suis venu
vous voir d'ailleurs pour cette finale
extrêmement longue que vous avez le
mérite de de commenter jusqu'au bout et
c'est vrai que ben ça peut sur cette
partie de ce niveau là c'est vrai que ça
peut traîner en longueur la cadence est
vraiment incroyablement l'ongle longue
pardon dans l'air moderne
après c'est bien
quand il reste plus qu'une partie
c'est pas facile à animer et c'est vrai
que là on est un peu obligé de parler
d'autres choses que des échecs
on va aller sur Magnus on va parler sur
ma news vous inquiétez pas donc là il se
passe rien et c'est même Abdou
qui est en train d'essayer après
ça va être dur de bouger ouais les sauts
dans ce genre de position quand on voit
la très bonne production qui la
réalisait hier dans sa finale contre
Magnus je vois je ressens la nulle allez
on va aller directement si tu le veux
bien alors Magnus et pragnananda
et saut tu nous avais annoncé très tôt
pas assez d'ambition veut faire nuls tu
nous l'avais dit j'espérais qu'il
veuille faire un peu mieux mais non
alors pour Marius on avait préconisé ce
plan là vous avez les flèches qu'on
attendait et ben regardez c'est pas loin
de la vérité il y a eu tous trois donc
c'est l'équivalent de ce qu'on avait vu
dame D1 et oui on avait dit on va la
transférer à l'eldame et tout donc
globalement tu vois le riz on était en
vrai vous aussi c'est cavaliers à Cannes
en fait c'est hyper dur à jouer cette
position avec les pièces noires
et il sait pas trop quoi faire de ces
pièces et Magnus a de l'amélioration
avec ses cavaliers positions à manœuvre
à structure fixe les pions ne bougent
pas donc les cavaliers font des bons un
peu partout et les fous ils ont pas de
grandes diagonales pour s'exprimer juste
à cause de ces deux pions là qui sont
bloqués et ça favorise énormément le jeu
blanc voilà
donc il va se faire travailler Prague on
a dit cette position
manus il est obligé de gagner
il n'a pas gagné hier et il a une
véritable position de torture à
valoriser
c'est son moment et je pense qu'il est
quand même plutôt content de ce qu'il a
obtenu ah oui
il l'a provoqué le petit coup baisser
je vois bien ma news
on provoque les affaiblissements et sur
B5 on prend la case
ce genre de position qui est dur aussi
pour les pour les noirs on a tous connu
ce genre d'opposition ou c'est nous
pendant longtemps qui qui souffrons et
c'est difficile de reprendre davantage
de te faire quelque chose et même quand
bien même on y arrive on a perdu des
forces et du temps au passage donc pas
évident
je regardais un truc enfin tout je me
suis est-ce que le Prague il a trouvé
sur tour B3 tour B8 peut-être parce
qu'il y a la fourchette si tu veux ici
ou je suis en train de regarder tu vois
de m'amuser un peu au fil de l'eau et je
me suis dit qu'il y a peut-être Dame des
7 vous serez de la folie
bon visiblement ça marche pas du tout
donc là la fourchette est complètement
jouable je suis en train de regarder
cette position de m'amuser avec cette
position je bouffe
et je me suis tiens comment je ressens
mon cavalier ah ben en fait
j'avais presque bon mais il y a pas
besoin de ressortir le cavalier on
croque le pion B6 sans doute
voilà ce qui m'avait manqué dans le
calcul parce que je voyais pas comment
cavaler sortait de sa prison et il ne
sortez pas donc je m'amusais un petit
peu parce que je voudrais bien tourbé
trois moi à la place de Magnus ou dame
B3 ah oui je préfère encore
c'est plus pro dame V3 puisque ma tour
joue déjà la dame elle fait rien je mets
ma dame en B3 autant pour moi je
reprends mon coup j'ai le droit je l'ai
pas joué je l'avais joué vite fait dans
ma tête dans mes trois pour on va
travailler donc
pourquoi bah parce que c'est Laurent
qu'il a expliqué hier et puis on vous
l'a déjà dit avec stouf les pions de
reculent pas donc on va essayer de les
faire avancer pour qu'il soit de plus en
plus faible et qui laisse des trous au
passage ici le rite d'un B3 je vise
l'histoire il joue B5 bon je sais pas
trop comment il défend autrement il peut
pas jeunesse d'imprimer
5 et le gélatine j'installe le gros à la
hausse et là bon c'est c'est trop dur
quoi je sais pas ce qu'il a prévu il a
dû prévoir quelque chose Prague
donc la tactique alors on nous dit à la
tactique on nous a dit qu'il y avait
cavalier 1,7
ok donc on va prendre
pour voir pour voir et du coup là c'est
tout F3 la petite scarabaté Magnus sans
doute parce que d'un mec froid
tour 8 3 8 mais tout rêve 3 c'est chiant
parce que maintenant qu'on me le dit
c'est beaucoup plus facile donc je vois
la récupération ici et là bim gg4 si on
vient en protection quoi
c'est vraiment étonnant de la part de
Magnus grand champion donc un valet
prend F7 c'était largement dans ses
cordes
alors je pense que si la rate parce que
peut-être des choses on va regarder
peut-être un coup comme c'est 7 non ça a
l'air dur
si la rater c'est qu'il est trop content
de sa position il veut le torturer son
adversaire
et du coup il l'a raté ça alors comment
on défend ici quand F7 il y a peut-être
vu quand même
parce que si vous voulez qu'on a
l'avantage qu'on va pouvoir torturer
l'adversaire pendant plusieurs heures on
ne doit pas mettre en danger sa position
on doit pas jouer dynamique on doit pas
chambouler la position sauf si on gagne
on a le droit de le faire
là il a peut-être trouvé quelque chose
qui tiendrait à moitié pour les Noirs
j'avoue que je peine le riz à trouver
quelque chose avec un noir
pour l'instant lave-vaisselle
revient juste
bon je vais jouer tout E5 sur pion
ça peut pas être jouable parce que après
j'attaque des cinq donc maintenant que
la tour j'attaque là donc
j'ai l'impression alors je vais vérifier
parce que là on n'avait pas vu alors je
mets des variantes pour voir cavalier 1
F7 alors c'est Dame des 7 directement un
Dame des 7 directement pas c'est ce
qu'on disait cavalier le 5 ou 30 pour
prendre
si je vous Détroit vraiment une bonne
gueule avec Dame des deux
pour D8 pour défendre ça franchement
des trois cheval
et le régler décliner cette proposition
Magnus pourquoi pas c'est dans les corps
du champion du monde de se dire après
pourquoi chat il y a peut-être plus de
boulot
en fait il est déjà tellement bien
et en fait ça laisse les Noirs jouer
hein
ça donne plus de coups bizarres c'est
plus bizarre mais bon ça a l'air quand
même d'être du
pas terrible quand même
OK
je pense que si j'avais vu qu'il y avait
dans une partie puisqu'on peut tous le
rater aussi trop concentré par l'aspect
stratégique de la position la position
est plutôt sèche
ça peut se rater ça peut se rater mais
quand même si on le voit on a envie de
le faire
c'était difficile à trouver ce qu'il
fallait faire avec les Noirs en prime il
y avait une ligne éventuellement
embêtante faudrait voir la conférence de
presse alors c'est tour B3 qui a été
choisi par Magnus bon il y avait les
deux coups alors on va gratter le petit
pion pour créer la case c'est on va lui
faire mal donc tomber trois et Prague il
trouve dames et 7
d'accord voilà l'idée de Prague
alors
si je prends du cavalier ouais je sais
pas trop en fait il y a peut-être des
arnaques
tout reprend B6 on attaque je vois pas
en fait
voilà il nous demande de bien calculer
par hasard ouais mais comme manus
commençait à le torturer qu'il avait pas
envie de laisser la casse C5
on peut se demander ce qu'il a vu quoi
vous cherchez la compensation que lui il
a pu voir
et
ce chat
complètement
on laisse le chercher comme ça on fait
rien alors vas-y on se met on se met
tranquille on se met tranquille avec
Lorie on attend un petit peu vos
demandes et comme ça je vais regarder un
peu le chat là j'étais trop trop
concentré j'essayais j'essayais de
trouver les variantes qui avaient pu
voir Magnus c’était pas si évident quand
même je vais enlever d'ailleurs
du coup trop B3 dames c'est ça tu sais
pas ce que mettait l'ordi de toute façon
je crois que je peux prendre des deux
pièces
parce que ma tour B3 est protégée donc
pourquoi pas faire caille en V6
après je reviens
ça a l'air un peu kata
alors pourquoi Magnus réfléchit pas
parce qu'il peut prendre des deux pièces
donc en fait il essaie de trouver quel
est le meilleur coup pratique du jeu il
veut revenir avec ses tours B8 tours C8
essaie de retrouver du jeu là bon c'est
pas impossible mais ça serait plutôt sur
des imprévisions de Magnus que là il a
un gros avantage clairement on voit la
jauge un avantage d'un pion net
c'est un peu plus qu'un pion parce que
le Fuger 7 est coincé va perdre de fou
je joue pas
son assez naturelles les pièces
meilleures sont plus fortes
positionnel maintenant peut-être qu'on
va la voir matériel aussi exactement
c'est un transfert d'avantage c'est très
intéressant ce que tu dis Laurie on a
bien travaillé la position et Praga
céder un pion voilà
j'ai l'impression que je souffre
bah il est en train de préparer sa
soirée non est-ce que c'est ça sauf une
visite là
j'en ai connu des des personnages qui
visitent des villes comme ça et qui sont
parce qu'il est bien accompagné
peut-être potentiellement il est bien
accompagné tu vois s'il est avec des
personnes comme Barbie sous on peut
imaginer qu'il fait pas que visiter quoi
voilà
il voit du pays
en tout cas merci pour le petit passage
le petit coucou et
[Musique]
et du coup la position est kata est-ce
qu'on irait pas alors chaud et Abdou
satoras je propose de pas aller les voir
on boycote un petit peu la partie elle
est pas franchement rigolote on ira voir
ce qui se passe quelque chose vous nous
courante
voilà on vient d'avoir la nul ça a pas
bougé quasiment Wesley il fait une
forteresse comme hier il va faire
alors c'est une finale mais très
déséquilibré père de fou pour une belle
paire de fois active pour carwana mais
il y a quand même un pion de plus pour
les noirs
on va voir la séquence
tac tac à carbonara apparemment avait
fait une grosse partie il avait
l'avantage on s'était quitté sur
cavalier G3
à cause de faux projets B4
cavalier prend 4 a été joué
là un petit peu étonnant il a préféré
prendre un cadre du pion de laissant
ainsi son fou un peu enterré
d'accord pourquoi pas ou à 4 c'est
marrant de défendre le cavalier en
faisant X4 défense indirecte tu
m'attaque s'attaque assez un des
conseils en général enfin moi je vais
déconseiller ça rapidement débutant
c'est que souvent on attaqué on se base
et on se retrouve au final avec
plusieurs pièces attaquées parce qu'on
n'a pas vu un petit coin intermédiaire
par exemple donc à éviter on essaye
plutôt de défendre de
de contrôler la menace de la part et de
voilà de se sauver ces pièces avant de
chercher autre chose et plus loin
après on voit que les joueurs eux de
très haut niveau peuvent faire ce type
de défense indirect parce que ce sont
des supers calculateurs donc tout était
tout était ok c'est à dire que surprise
F3 qui fait peur parce que façon qu'on
va se faire un truc fou français 6 ça
attaque la tour ou même sans être un
super calculateur pour le coup c'est
facile de voir que il y a une qualité en
l'air du coup cavalier béca a été joué
je cherche une case avec mon cavalier où
je vais être gênant et il est un peu
l'immunité diplomatique du fait ma data
au bordel puisque surtout ce qui est
génial c'est que là dans la position on
a quand même une case à la case D3 c'est
ce qu'on veut on aimerait placer une
pièce dessus et un cavalier si on
pouvait on voit que le cavalier en C6 il
en est loin mais on est très loin on se
demande quel changement on pourrait
prendre et en fait le fait qu'il y a la
pièce attaquée en F3 chez les Blancs ça
fait qu'on peut en deux coups
c'est encore plus beau parce qu'on
pourra prendre un F3 et après prendre en
BK on peut regarder ça prise là et après
on peut croquer en B4
dans de bonnes conditions la tour et ce
pion là devient pas assez c'est l'idée
de timer à ce moment-là jolie donc d'un
point D8 a été joué
par Fabiano et surtout référend D8 il a
joué carré des cartes
offrant ainsi la case D3 infirmière mais
la vue une petite pointe il a dit je
t'offre des trois mais tu payes quelque
chose en échange kssi
attention tu m'attaque défense indirect
tu as vu Laurie ils aiment ça tu vois
nous casser les pieds pour nous faire
calculer
et attention il vit surtout le fou sur
eux cet échec et sur Wi-Fi j'ai encore
échec donc là si je prends la rage donne
deux pièces pour une tour c'est trop
cher donc pour 8 a été joué cavalier
prend le sac quand même merci pour la
paire de fou
a disparu à ce moment-là pourtant il a
une grosse paire de fou et un gros pion
de moi aussi mais il est pas encore
passé ce pion de moi le Fuge ici c'est
une actif aussi petit avantage blanc
quand même
5 et rendre ses tours j'aime bien les
blancs ici le riz parce que le pion de
moins on le sent pas par contre la jolie
paire de fonds
et puis il y a une tour qui est rentré
[Musique]
c'est un petit peu dur c'est un petit
peu dur donc FC jouet pour le roi sans
doute un jour
et parce qu'il comprend que son fou est
complètement nul et qu'il s'occupe de sa
moins bonne pièce donc l'idée
et là on parlait des défenses indirectes
regardez le coup de Fabiano cawana pour
8 il y a quelque chose qui se passe au
niveau des fous je m'en fous poussez ça
pour ces 7 m'en fous toujours du faux A4
de fou tu veux échanger
les deux couleurs je joue fouder un
bravo comme piano retour 2 est-ce que ça
va suffire pour gagner c'est pas sûr
mais qu'est-ce que c'est bon
stratégiquement
mais vous voyez l'activité forte des
pièces blanches c'est difficile à jouer
pour Vincent camer
qui n'est peut-être pas moins bien selon
la jauge mais je peux vous assurer qu'en
pratique
si on a des idées avec les blancs avec
les Noirs c'est quand même plus
difficile Fatou
regarde la position le placement des
pièces
dont
toujours cette classe des trois ce
cavalier
un petit manque d'activité quand même on
a des techniques qui bougent pas trop de
la 8e rangée exactement et c'est deux je
pense qu'on reste cavalier des trois en
fait peut-être et du coup ton fou il est
un peu bête maintenant que le cavalier
est venu en Détroit il paraît plus
naturel parce que je te dis tout le
temps on fait des coups de pieds donc
toi tu fais pousser deux c'est normal et
bim qui a aidé trois chiant
maintenant faudrait que je rejoue fouder
un
par exemple
par exemple alors que là tour C8
si j'en D3 je me prends full G4 dans la
tronche et ça va être une autre histoire
et F5 n'est pas jouable
un difficulté il est possible qu'à un
moment on voit en cavalier arriver avec
des couches de cartes éventuelles et
après on va taper toutes les faiblesses
adversaires
normalement on donne pas sa paire de fou
mais si on a une excuse ou une
concession adverse en échange pourquoi
pas donc c'est toujours à surveiller les
blancs sont maître de la tension et ça
ferait voler en éclat le riz la
structure adverse tu aimes bien les
squelettes d'options il n'y aurait plus
mais un squelette un peu cassé
beaucoup de beaucoup de fracture plein
de vidéos j'aimerais pas franchement
pas trop trop envie
c'est très dur
ça serait dur ok du coup dans ces
conditions
de trouver
de trouver les solutions et s'il va se
faire torturer c'est pas une aussi
grande torture que Prague mais on voit
c'est les positions que quand c'est
d'infectionne et carwana fait une jolie
normal sans doute pour gêner la tour
tourbé 6 et rebondir peut-être en C5
on virevolt et il nous a donné
exactement et vous rappelez la menace
Fougères
et je pouvais pas jouer F5
ben il y a des fonds
dans le camp noir voilà un cahier
pieuvre on comprend pourquoi il y a
plein de tentacules voilà l'histoire
alors mais en fait c'est tentacules
cervelle tape sur rien par contre mon
fou qui va arriver en G4
il va faire mal alors il a c'est
terrible quasiment
parce que du coup ce que dit le chat
c'est vrai
vous voulez aller sur cette case donc
c'est tentant il y a
tout qui nous dit d'y aller sauf du
couple a la position actuelle en fait on
a envie mais non on ne peut pas on peut
pas parce que c'est
perdu cette position touristique je vais
pas le jouer il y aura plus il faut
aussi s'échec et change et je perds mais
c'est pire tour des vitres regardez je
vais faire pousser cette et merci pour
le retour la paire de fou
évidemment mais vous avez tous vu faut
aussi s'échappe qui gagne à tour et ça y
est voilà comment on perd une partie
donc faux amis des fois les belles cases
mais si une belle case c'est aussi une
case où j'exerce une pression je fais
mal à l'adversaire faites mal aux
adversaires ils nous embêteront pas
pendant ce temps-là cahier des trois
qu'est-ce qu'on menace rien bon moi
fougère j'aime beaucoup
très beaucoup on peut on peut aussi
avoir la MP3 on la garde en tête mais
n'est pas obligé d'y aller tout de suite
c'est à dire qu'à un moment on peut
retourner peut-être passer par ces cinq
aussi plus tard dans la position mais
voilà faut voir le comme disait Kevin au
tout début l'urgence de la position ça
c'est important c'est une question très
très importante qu'elle a priorité dans
la position et vous y répondez pour
démarrer votre plan aux échecs dans
cette position je veux attaquer le roi
de verses défendre mon roi activez mes
pièces restreindre des pièces adverses
casser la structura adverse améliorer ma
structure etc etc tout en ayant une
réflexion double sens pour moi c'est
très bien mais soyez pas trop égoïste
pensez aussi à votre adversaire c'est
hyper important et n'oubliez pas on a
cité beaucoup de critères le roi
l'activité la structure de pion on a dit
pour garder ça double sens et faut pas
oublier la méfiance avec le radar
il faut avant de faire de la stratégie
et
position il faut bien penser le riz à la
tactique qui peut
changer toute une partie chambouler un
diagnostic bien fait sur une position la
tactique clim sur la stratégie
exactement
les pièces bien sûr bien sûr tout à fait
domination stratégique qui est souvent
récompense par une tactique
alors qu'un raté le gain non on peut pas
dire ça en fait on a regardé donc là il
a fait quel progressif je pensais que ça
quasiment pareil et surtout à B8 il a
joué cavalier à 4 je trouvais ça assez
content tout comme tout reprend mes 6
honnêtement tout à l'heure j'ai pas eu
envie de me faire suer je me suis on
verra ce que je vous ramenus si je vous
ras sans doute le meilleur coup
[Musique]
j'ai
ça fait penser que tout reprend ici
c'est qu'il y avait promet ici c'est à
peu près la même chose voilà
j'ai regardé dans le chat j'ai vu qu'on
buggé ah oui et ça malheureusement comme
je vous ai dit on n'a pas la main sur le
stream on a quand même la main sur les
coups qu'on joue etc mais le stream mais
est toasté par une solution extérieure
donc je peux mettre un petit mot
[Musique]
je peux je peux le demander mais c'est
un peu tard je suis désolé pour toi moi
je l'avais préparé comme ça je reste je
reste secrète de se cacher et d'ailleurs
il y a le rapprochement hier c'était
slash Laurent Frayssinet alors que
j'avais quand même mis/ techpress qui
lui va quand même mieux parce qu'il a
redécouvert discorde hier et du coup il
est pas mal dans son style on est deux
bons compères à ce niveau là au niveau
technique
et je mets votre petit mot à la Régie
tant que ça coupe pas comme tout à
l'heure ça reste OK
tactique c'est court terme stratégie
chez le long terme
je vais vous dire quand même pour vous
régaler je vais vous mettre ce que j'ai
dit à Vanessa qui a la régie j'ai mis ah
il Vanessa viewers
en plus j'ai fait des fautes
d'orthographe
little breaks in the stream voilà ce que
je voulais en tout cas écrire j'ai pas
trop écrit ça mais bon c'était c'était
l'idée
est-ce que c'est je me dis j'ai pas eu
besoin de Google Traduction pour ça
c'est sûr
alors c'était quoi la question débutant
que j'ai
et nous sommes de retour avec suite à
votre demande on a essayé de débriefer
avec la régie
peut-être que ce sont les caméras des
joueurs si vous voulez du coup ça
alourdit forcément le stream vous avez
raté notre discussion en anglais je suis
content de les micro soient coupés à ce
moment-là parce que je cherche mes mots
il y a que faire quoi c'est bien
positionné quoi
et j'étais en train de vous répondre
dans le chat c'est même pas tout un
moment qui m'a traduit ce que Vanessa la
régie était en train de dire parce que
moi je parle pas mais je parle pas je
traduis l'anglais et puis je laisse
Kevin prendre la parole et en plus ouais
c'est dur ouais c'est ça c'est ça Fatou
et c'est vrai que c'est dur d'être sur
les deux les deux choses en même temps
autant les échecs et répondre au chat ça
va mais faire de l'anglais et en même
temps
voilà c'est cet été c'était terrible ce
moment on s'en est sorti vous nous dites
s'il y a des petits des petits sauts
dans dans le stream mais c'est vrai que
les cames peuvent alors dire un petit
peu ça dépend de la connexion de la
régie aussi
demain sera la mienne sera ma technique
ma connexion on verra si c'est mieux ou
non pas sur doute du tout parce qu'on va
voir effectivement c'est un stream qui
est assez lourd avec les cames donc on
verra bien quand on y sera demain stream
avec Mathieu cornet
voilà voilà pour cette dernière du
Tassin demain c'est la dernière onde
d'ailleurs vous connaissez sans doute
l'horaire de la dernière on
tous les jours on était en stream à
partir de 14 heures
et demain on sera en stream à partir de
midi
change complètement ça me fait penser
que j'ai oublié de prévenir chez moi
avec sa changer je trouve que l'horaire
est pas mal il faut pas que je me plante
l'Internet breton est de haute
technologie oui de l'autre technologie
farfouille auvitch puisque en fait j'ai
pas la fibre chez moi Fatou donc
j'utilise la solution
d'Elon musk par de
l'Internet par satellite qui était la
seule solution si je voulais streamer
parce que autant faire des vidéos style
YouTube et autres c'est facile même avec
une sorte de mauvaise connexion une
connexion domestique basique si la DSL
par contre pour streamer il faut la
fibre ou au moins la solution d'Iron
musk qui qui est l'Internet par
satellite mais si on peut avoir la fibre
à la maison c'est quand même plus cool
voilà
voilà voilà
en tout cas c'est bien revenu c'est très
c'est super voilà on a fait une mini
pause et ça vous fait bien marrer
d'ailleurs quand on part et qu'on
prévient pas mais ça se passe comme ça
ici
sachez que si on n'est pas là c'est
qu'on est en pause et maintenant vous
préviens plus c'est comme ça alors manus
il a fait caca je sais pas trop pourquoi
c'est pas bon bah si on pouvait jouer
tout romber 6 ok
histoire est-ce que il y a une histoire
il a trouvé par visiblement tous les
coups
il a changé il faut prendre 5 pourquoi
c'est gênant
on n'a pas tout reprendre 500 doutes à
cause de
ça fait que je dois changer la structure
pas tout et peut-être qu'il y aura un
écart de Prague pour trouver du jeu si
la structure change la structure change
pas tout se réveille
totalement attention à la partie change
totalement
la structure change la partie change
nous dit Fatou et c'est tout à fait vrai
normalement qu'on a la domination quand
on torture l'adversaire on est laissé de
garder la même structure de garder la
même position pour torturer l'adversaire
qui n'apprécie pas ce qu'on lui fait et
est-ce que on pouvait en tout premier 6
il n'y avait pas de changement de
structure
c'est ça qui a laissé échappé Magnus
vraisemblablement avec est-ce que il y
avait foudé 7 question pour mettre
pression là pression là et c'est ce que
Manu ça peut être craint
il y a une pression de partout regardez
cette et là il y avait peut-être le coup
à trouver c'est là que Magnus a
peut-être raté quelque chose
comment jouer cette position je pense
qu'il a eu peur de cela
il a trouvé plus safe
et cette position il s'est dit c'est
chaud et en même temps quand je la vois
je me dis c'est chaud mais il y a
peut-être quelque chose à trouver ici
pour
pour les blancs
draguer et en difficulté au temps mais
s'il y a une position un peu plus
agréable à jouer il peut peut-être s'en
sortir quand même
et ça ça défile donc et cette position
est-ce qu'il y avait un coucou allez je
peux vous dire je vais accélérer et il y
avait cavalier prend des 7 ok c'est ce
que j'aurais joué mais il y a tout
reprend des 7 et là je savais plus quoi
jouer
voilà ce manus ça a raté et il fallait
simplement revenir en D1
pourquoi serait logique puisque mon
cavalier en 4 il est bizarre
qu'est-ce que je joue ma tour et attaqué
il y a toujours le motif des quatre que
je viens de montrer c'est encore plus
précis que Praga jouer
est-ce que Magnus est en train de tester
il s'est fait un peu avoir
mal news qui voulait torturer Prague
tranquillement à laisser échapper et
peut-être qu'il aurait dû prendre plus
son temps sur cette décision je pense
que Magnus pour une fois il a pas trop
maîtrisé il a fait une partie parfaite
la décision du 22e coup faudrait voir
quasi parfaite du coup mais là c'est
quand même la boulette avec pas mal de
temps j'ai l'impression qu'il a laissé
un peu filer le gain ou au moins le bon
avantage de torture Fatou et que
maintenant après cette séquence qu'on
vient de voir le petit Prague il est en
train de s'activer et trouve les coups
pragans hier il a fait une mauvaise
partie aujourd'hui il est quand même
présent ce qui a une position difficile
contre le champion du monde parce que
Laurent tenait absolument à ce qu'on
qualifie Carlsen comme le champion du
monde c'est vrai qu'il l'est jusqu'à
avis avril prochain puisqu'il a lâché
son titre il ne se représente pas
il ne brille pas un nouveau mandat
Carlsen
pas mal Cyril c'est mignon comme tout
et oui mais non bah c'est très bien ce
que tu nous dis bon guéri va s'en sortir
nous limite sous roux on va aller les
voir si ça te va tout
parce que apparemment
ça a glissait entre les mains devant de
Forest l'avantage mais c'était chaud ou
alors il y a du coup rouge ou la
coccinelle là ce que nous font les
joueurs mais évidemment c'est beaucoup
plus difficile enfin tout c'est position
d'ordinateur très calculatoire pour les
joueurs humains pour prendre
et là il s'est planté apparemment
F4 en même temps assez logique et là
guérisse est complètement trompé avec
tour G7 Amphion keto mais on sait pas
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui est ouais et
apparemment dans le chat tu nous disent
c'était trop dur les variantes
c'est hyper chaud le déséquipe matériel
est présent il faut être très très
précis
comment on aurait attaqué
pour C1 était joué ici
j'avais envie de regarder des comme toi
F3 tours mais attention au modèle
anti-jeux F3
il y a toujours l'avantage matériel pour
guéri
et on voit caniche guéri a réussi son
pari
de rester en vie au niveau du temps
enfin tout
oui
[Musique]
c'est pas évident c'est pas évident
on peut retrouver le lien alors il
arrive à trouver plein de
plein de coups dans ce sens là après la
variante qu'on avait vu bah non pour ça
car il faudrait tard
c'est pas simple mais je sais pas ce
qu'il a loupé et du coup si le chat dit
que c'était difficile
on fait confiance au chat néanmoins on
va chercher et si on trouve pas dans ces
positions très calculatoires là on
mettra l'ordi mais on nous dit c'était
très difficile alors c'est un beau défi
pour nous d'avoir les idées nous
permettant de faire mal alors garde des
coups comme cavalier prend F7
éventuellement c'est plutôt la commencer
échec prise menace bien sûr je regarde
le coup complet parce que vous voyez je
me dis tout rêve pour un F7 et là je
vous montre un très joli motif mais j'ai
fait très mal joué l'adversaire voilà
super cool pour ces cas-là cavalier
prend F7 évidemment ça serait un maté
des
classico bon sur cavalier prend F7
vucanis je viens de jouer tour gs7 il
aurait pris de la tour G
est-ce qu'on peut encore enfoncer le
clou
dans cette situation
on a quand même du monde franchement
c'est tentant qu'elle va aller prendre
F7 même si pour un F7 derrière mais j'ai
envie de ramener la tour à la fête et
toujours ce dame bien à la noix
c'est pas facile je viens de donner un
cavalier j'ai intérêt de prouver
derrière
j'ai une idée quand même Fatou je vais
te dire ce que je vois mais bon j'ai une
idée si c'est bon cavalier prend pour
prendre Dame des quatre
ah non ça fonctionne pas
dame Descartes mon idée c'est d'avoir
des fous prends un F7 parce que je
voulais en fait jouer
pour faire chaque email je vous
montrerai
c'est pas ça visiblement au moins ah
peut-être parce que la jauge j'ai même
mis un en fait maintenant j'ai idée tout
pour F3 tours G3 ramener du monde à la
fête si tu veux sauf que j'ai pas envie
de me faire banane par dame B1 ok donc
ça me gêne donc je voulais jouer Dame
des cas
l'arnaque c'était de jouer foopra F7
avec la dame en l'air un peu bateau mais
surtout la seconde idée c'était de jouer
tout pour F3
c'est assez classe et sur dindeka tient
super coup noir qui me dégoûte
c'est cavalier 2
faut prendre et il m'enlève le matos
plus de pièces pour attaquer donne une
pièce pour simplifier la position et
enlever mon pouvoir d'attaque alors je
recherche
je recherche je recherche
donc cavalier privé c'était le bon coup
et c'est pas facile parce que enfin
c'est le bon coup c'est la jauge qui me
le dit peut-être je sais pas c'était le
bon coin en fait pour j'ai pris F7 et
j'arrive pas à trouver quand même ouais
ouais
j'ai pas mis encore les variantes mais
c'était logique j'ai envie de
j'ai envie comment dirais-je d'y aller
mais
alors comment je passe là aidez-moi dans
le chat là j'ai fait le gros du boulot
je vous offre cavalier pour F7 comme ça
pas tout ça toi maintenant hein
j'offre que le premier coup j'offre que
le premier coup de la variante sinon
c'est trop de cadeaux
[Musique]
la Tour Eiffel est obligé de rester là
donc faudrait que je fasse le travail
avec la dame mesdames ne fonctionnent
pas ou je reste au contact de mon fou
j'ai aussi vous prendre cette tendance à
cette position et 8 peut-être que je
peux ah alors je vais essayer ça c'est
pas normal de jouer comme ça parce que
la pièce est clouée c'est simplement
pour amener madame
et ensuite ramener ma tour aller chante
ça
punaise c'est pas ça non plus ça fait
que des échecs et il me dit nul
c'était pas illogique pourtant bordel
Dame des 8 comme ça il y aura plus d'un
Bénin
c'est chaud ouais bon nul allez j'ai
fait nul j'ai pas fait mieux contre à
Nice j'ai pas réussi
mon achat déjà avant de mettre l'ordi
c'est impossible à voir ok ok
c'est déjà bien contre Aniche bon
malheureusement j'aurais pas fait la
partie avant du coup oh là là là là
ah ouais et le retour du petit à trois
ici
à trois meilleurs coups on avait parlé
de ce à trois mais pas là pas là d'un B2
et roi H2 non mais arrête quoi arrête
mais oui mais ça a du sens quand même
puis ça fait sens par rapport à ce que
tu disais justement maintenant je
pourrais pas me prendre mais c'est dur à
trouver quand même et puis quel sang
froid de leur dire en fait qui est une
supercalculette donc il a pas d'histoire
de sang-froid c'est-à-dire que j'ai
quand même une tour de moins
visuellement même si j'ai au moins une
pièce de moins parce que je vais
récupérer la Tour Eiffel et franchement
c'était chaud enfin tout
salut à tous
non mais c'était c'était beau c'était
beau
tu as essayé de parler Fatou et je t'ai
coupé nous direct panda et ben je m'en
excuse je m'en excuse voilà l'habitude
j'ai très bien
c'était pire encore non j'ai beaucoup
parlé là je vais laisser parler Fatou un
peu celle qui va donner des explications
mais là la position était pas facile
aussi j'avais pas envie de lui refiler
la patate chaude parce que là elle
chaude pour les joueurs aussi qui sont
2700 donc c'était pas forcément un gros
cadeau on va arriver sur la position
finale on va aller voir ce qui s'est
passé comme ça fat tout va nous faire un
débrief tour c'est un cavalier A4
toujours sur ce petit cavalier B2
et là je leur donne il a pris peur il a
joué dans B3 il voulait pas perdre son
fou d'enfant ou prend et il se dit on va
jouer la petite finale
c'est pas mal dans les pièces sont pas
très bien mises la tour en fion de
créteaux est pas top en fait tout fais
nous un petit bilan de la position
comment tu sens les choses qui va gagner
dans cette partie est-ce que tu peux
tout nous dire
bien sûr je peux tout vous dire on était
parti du coup avec un une sacrée un
sacrifice de qualité chez les Blancs
bon il y a un pion aussi
et l'idée c'était qu'ils avaient une
extrême attaque extrême civil dit parce
que du coup ça a été ça a été défendu
mais on était pour l'attaque on joue
pour la taque et là le fait d'échanger
je pense que pour moi ça va tendre vers
la nul on va
facilement en tout cas mais oui ça
paraît logique
après la position où on allait on peut
parler des îlots on parle de structures
de pions le retour des structures
tu connais
qu'est-ce que tu en penses de la
structure
et seulement deux chez les Blancs on a
un bloc
voilà je me suis amusé avec les couleurs
j'aurais pu faire du dessin je pense
que tu peux
donc là on a trois soutenir chez les
Blancs
il y en a aucun c'est que des cibles
donc ça les fragilise un peu des pions
bouffent
du coup je vois mal
je
me pose une question d'un coup tu vois
je regarde cavalier F2
sens ça fait sens mais on peut peut-être
aller mettre notre tour en dés et ça
ressort quand même ouais mais je voulais
je voulais te ah oui je voulais faire un
truc qui marche pas du tout je vais
faire tout ces deux pour t'attraper le
cavalier sur cavalier des trois faire
tourner le 2
sauf que tu vas sortir par D1 cavalier
F2 fatum fait tour des 8 pour ressortir
mais elle vise pas la case des trois
elle va sortir par D1 surtout c'est
tourbé
8 je te fais tourner
tu vas me faire tourner deux
ressortir le cavalier tu m'as menti
pas terrible
que dalle en fait cavalier F2 déjà je
gagnais pour G8
tour des 8 tu vas gagner maintenant en
fait j'étais content de mon truc je
voulais je voulais piéger le cavalière
vous comprenez je pense que je veux
faire
tourbé 1 je me suis dit ça tout je vais
faire provoquer trois et je vais
attraper le cavalier en exerçant un
couage ça paraît maintenant sur le
papier mais tourbé un il y a tout des
deux et j'ai l'air d'un gland voilà
je me suis fait je me suis fait banane
donc on avait parlé des tours
j'ai oublié la puissance de tes tours
et je me suis dit tiens je vais la
banane si elle fait carré des trois je
reprends mon piège tout pour des deux
vous voyez toujours même thème sauf
qu'elle va me faire gagner quoi pas de
bol donc il y a pas d'enfermement pour
Jordan
du coup il a été pragmatique il a joué
tour B1 le mieux placé
ça c'est une question un peu
de fou
le plus fort à la limite le plus fort
le mieux
fort mais il y a pas de pion passé si tu
veux Eva dans cette position salut Gaïa
ça fait plaisir de te voir il y a
beaucoup de faiblesses beaucoup de cible
puisqu'ils sont isolés
parce que ça peut vite changer mais
on a d'ailleurs pas de bon pion peu de
répondre comme ça Eva c'est on répond à
l'inverse un petit peu de ta question on
n'a pas de pion passé
on a une belle activité
parce qu'on a un fou quand même et un
pion contre une tour un demi pion de
moins compensé par une belle activité
égale à peu près cette position
[Musique]
à rien tout à fait Fatou tout à fait
parce que ça va être au tempo près et là
j'ai un problème quand même je dirige je
joue des trois il y a tourner c'est plus
un problème tactique Fatou c'est un
problème professionnel tour des trois si
je continue à cavalier B4 attention
ça peut ça peut rentrer ça peut être la
fuite d'eau là côté côté de guéri
attention quand même j'ai peut-être F5
défense de ranger
une défense possible et si on échange
les tours après il y a plus de problème
de justement je rentre mon septième
rangée alors
beaucoup mieux attends mais qu'est-ce
que je fous cavalier 3 ça marche pas du
tout j'ai des coups comme ça là
qu'est-ce que je vais faire et des trois
en fait j'avais pas vu Fatou mais il est
enfermé
du coup il a enfermé
mais ce malin Dani iris contre le jeu
c'est peut-être de jouer 8 et douloureux
je suis pressant avec son fort ils sont
chauds
on va regarder ton F5 Fatou
je crois que non
assure
ces deux F5
[Musique]
Fatou j'essaie de poser des problèmes là
je vous aime pas
j'ai fait exprès en fait je voulais je
voulais te piéger mais c'est peut-être
ça semble pas bon vu la jauge je vais
faire tourber 5 menacer ton cavalier
menacer la fourchette
mais j'y laisse des plumes je viens de
lâcher un pion
que tu m'as pris
c'est pas sympa et du coup je verrai
simplement récupérer la caloche c'est
peut-être pas suffisant en fait ce que
je fais
j'avais vu Cyril
semi piège mais la jauge ne m'a pas
suivi
sans doute qu'il y a peut-être un tour
projet 5 fois tout pour éliminer et
après bouger le Cavalo quelque chose
comme ça pour ranger 5 cavaliers 4
peut-être je sais pas en fait tu peux tu
peux trouver exactement
avec la même idée en plus tout à l'heure
que l'accin vous êtes pénible dans le
chat vous trouvez les bons coups et du
coup
et du coup ma petite tactique marche pas
vous avez fait contre le point
d'intermédiaire bravo bravo matador
c'est un peu le thème de la soirée
exactement
amateur faut pas le faire mais on voit
que les joueurs de haut niveau bah ils
jouent sur le fil les acrobates très
clairement et c'est chaud donc poussez
deux F5 jouets on a trouvé quand même le
coup d'anis et comment on fait
maintenant avec les Blancs on n'a pas
trouvé là
fou des trois FX4 comment on fait
l'histoire
et ça joue ah ben c'est ça ils sont en
train de jouer la variante ça joue tout
tempo
recette et j'ai dit bon j'arrête là
j'étais un peu deg je me suis je pouvais
plus gagner
non mais je suis nul je peux peut-être
faire tourner
c'est ce qui a été joué regardez tout
recettes tour B4 on a trouvé tous les
coups
dès qu'on bouge les pièces on arrive à
voir quand même en fait
on a pas le droit de bouger les Picasses
on vous rappelle normalement
[Musique]
peuvent se refaire les noix ont chauffé
en fait je pense qu'il joue pour nul
parce que là maintenant j'ai deux pions
passés si j'arrive à les mettre en
marche je peux vous dire que à Nice il
va avoir chaud
c'est pas si facile de gober c'est 5
il a tout compris il joue à une vitesse
folle en plus je trouve les joueurs
ok parfois il prennent leur temps mais
dans les positions extrêmement chaudes
dans les positions comme celle-là ils
vont quand même très vite
s'il te plaît ils sont en 37e
[Musique]
c'est vraiment pas rigolo
il faut bien que
quand même pour Aniche il a trois coups
à jouer il faut pas qu'ils se plante
parce que il peut se rendre la vie de
très difficile
la jauge dit 03 donc ça doit être égal
mais il faut bien jouer encore c'est
plutôt les noirs que l'on a les
problèmes pratiques une des idées je
vous l'ai dit c'est de faire 4 5 et
après un fou blanc donc je pour éviter
les blocus sur les cases noires je
pousse mes pions sur noir si possible il
y a pas le droit d'avancer de deux en
deux comme ça mais je vais avancer en
bloc compact E4 E5 F5 F6 accompagné par
mon Roi et le fou le fou blanc reste bon
si
j'avance comme ça ben les tours vont
s'infiltrer et bloquer bloquer les pions
voilà une tour là une tour là
ce sera pas aussi fort non non mais
Annie je pense que s'il réfléchit c'est
qu'il trouve pas la position que si
facile il a 3 minutes il doit se
dépêcher c'est pas si simple
est-ce que il y a pas des idées
j'ai pas de crasse tu me fais pas ça le
coup ok je fais un rêve de
[Musique]
je suis hyper content de jouer ça en
pratique avec les Blancs même si la
jauge nous exprime que tout réussi c'est
sans doute un très bon coup Fatou
puisque tu vois la jauge à l'air
contente mais
si c'est 0 0 je trouve qu'il y a un côté
qui est vraiment plus favorable à jouer
oui est-ce que tu peux pas là maintenant
doubler
et en fait
[Musique]
ça t'empêche de rentrer si tu rentres tu
perds le fou tu as tes deux coups à
jouer tu dois monter ton roi pour
défendre le fou et le temps que tu fais
ça je double donc je vais le faire
pour pour la fin du stream
c'est tout à fait ça c'est chaud chez
Margus ben on va aller j'ai mal au 29 ok
j'ai une idée de qui tu es je m'alou 29
et je te salue spécifiquement et je dis
bonjour à tous ceux qui arrivent aussi
mais j'ai mal au 29 j'ai une idée j'ai
une idée après je peux me tromper
du coup c'est chaud chez Magnus et tour
des 8 il a pas trouvé ta défense Fatou
c'est une défense dynamique aussi mais
j'aime pas trop ce qu'il a fait je
préférais largement ce que tu as joué
avec la paralysé car tes pions E3 il
veut peut-être essayer de gagner il a
été croqué à deux
j'aime pas du tout je trouve ça risqué
on va voir on va chez Magnus c'est le
zainote
il reste 5 coups
de jouer vous avez vu ce petit coup de
Prague il met tout en pression F3 forcée
ou des 7
il joue très dynamique
ks-3 dames c'est 5 échecs
est arrivé très dynamique c'est très
bien
c'était pas prévu au programme
waouh
des Français trois dames prends des 7
parce que j'attaque la tour mais il a
joué ces deux pragies
laisse-la tours
qui donnent envie il y a E6 ça donne
envie je sais pas si c'est bon parce
qu'il y a des dames C7
et sinon peut-être dame D8 ce que donne
des 8 fait nul dame D8 c'est un dame
d'un F6
dame D8 attention parce que roi chaise
comment on fait nul alors on va chercher
on va trouver
rigolo
améliorer sa pause
dans ces trois
et maintenant est-ce que je peux faire
aussi dans de meilleures conditions
parce qu'il garde la casser cette hein
très important si un pion est préparé à
la dame
après moi aussi j'ai le droit de faire
aussi ce sac par exemple j'ai
l'impression que si c'est le coup de la
position
que si dans ces 7
F4 prise bon enfin tout j'ai envie de
d'essayer de faire une perpette parce
que j'ai peur de la dame de
perpète ou quoi mais tu as fait bien le
roi j'aurais bien réussi
avec au minimum
parce que si tu fais
[Musique]
peut-être faire si un dam d'ailleurs
quel bordel
allez c'est un dame
et là je ferais bien E7 on va faire nul
je pense je fais gaffe qu'il y a pas de
problème je menace dans mes fuites et
peut-être bien
et là tu m'arraches tout un F4 et je
dois être perpète intégrale c'était
chaud
ils ont très bien joué dommage à Manu
j'ai l'impression que ça fait partie
quasi parfaite aujourd'hui mais tombé
sur un Prague exceptionnel il a fait une
faute alors nous on a leur dit on a tout
qui lui a pas permis de torturer son
adversaire ça se joue sur un choix de
prises
différentes pièces donc
réfléchissez bien parce que ça arrive
très très souvent bah il y a un bon
choix on peut être variante une bonne
décision une mauvaise de loi d'une
mauvaise ou etc etc donc faut bien
réfléchir avec quoi on prend puisque la
partie est peut être totalement
différente et là en l'occurrence on l'a
bien vu ici
et franchement oui c'est l'heure de la
conversion de l'avantage d'activité en
avantage matériel que ça c'est jouer il
a laissé trop de contre jeux à
l'adversaire Prague a pu prendre
l'initiative à ce moment-là on a vu
qu'il fallait faire tourner 6 à laisser
moins d'initiative même si vous êtes
était intéressant ça ne prenait pas
l'initiative comme dans la partie ou
après quel est prend B6 il y a une
avalanche de coups de coupe piquant
voilà changement de structure de pion
pas tous les aime et après des coups
piquants piquants piquant piquant encore
piquant encore
piquant même de chez Magnus prise
piquant parce que c'est C2 ça NAS
promotion piquant ça apprend en fait il
y a une séquence de folie de des deux
côtés très calculatoire basé sur
l'initiative et on arrive maintenant
dans cette position et il y en a
plusieurs qui sont exprimés dans le chat
pour nous dire moi j'ai une idée alors
je crois que c'est toi maugré
alors dame quand a peut-être à la fin on
a fait les petits explications je vois
bien Magnus jeu 6 ça fait sens de de
jouer sur le match ou la perpète là je
vais jouer F4 pour pas mettre mon roi en
H3 parce que là j'avais peur d'avoir les
gros problèmes regardez sur un choix
c'est un Dam
et là les menaces sont très présentes
sur mon roi je vais me faire ma tête
donc ça servait à rien d'où le petit F4
que j'ai joué tout à l'heure pour
planquer mon roi
donc qu'est-ce qui va le jouer
je sais plus c'était F4 tout à la fin
c'est un dame
le 7
je sais pas
ah ouais baisser la Tour Blanche en bas
pour insta qui la reine ouais c'est
chaud Adam il faut vraiment nous donner
des cases parce que sinon on galère
quand même pour comprendre tout ce que
vous voulez dire alors c'est pas grave
il faut prendre le temps ce que je sais
que vous faites pas nécessairement ça
tous les jours ce qui est notre cas mais
je pense oui au lieu de B4
ouais le B4 c'est pas gênant
et c'était quoi tout run
tout à ce que c'était pas nul tout de
suite
une dame
ah c'est pas bon Kevin apparemment je
voulais ah regarde je vais planter
perpète et en fait il y a dans ma carte
revient
vous dites comment les Noirs
continuaient bah peut-être on fait un
harcèlement d'un
[Musique]
comment vous allez alors tout droit vous
avez proposé dans le chat j'ai vu c'est
vrai que c'était intéressant je n'ai
plus cette thématique là ils vont en
faire nulle les deux joueurs alors pour
eux qu'est-ce qu'il y avait
je sens que ça va être bientôt nul
qu'est-ce qu'on faisait pour faire nul
puisque l'ordi nous le dit on doit
pouvoir trouver nulle assez facile à
gagner
[Musique]
ta mère
j'ai eu un problème j'ai cru qu'il y
avait ça
et du coup
il y a une perpète c'est dur à voir
ça va mais comme on a envie de faire
dame vous voyez il y a perpète
voilà donc il y a vraiment perpète donc
c'est vraiment facile en plus ok un
rouage de je suis allé sur la case il
fallait pas regarder ah oui donc
qu'est-ce que je fais sur ce coup-là
roi F1 il y a Dame des
oui c'est juste un échange en fait c'est
peut-être trois fois quand même
non j'ai pas le droit en fait de me dire
pourquoi ça marche
il fait dame D1 comme Dame des deux
qu'est-ce que c'est je délire
complètement Dame des trois voilà ça je
voyais pas et je me fais piquer la tour
ok donc où je vais avec mon roi je suis
content d'avoir joué pour eux vous me
disiez que c'était facile merci les
copains
je fais comment là pour m'en sortir
ouais fin Dame des trois rois HH
mais je me suis fait engueuler par
l'Ordinaire
j'ai eu peur hein
tu perdais ta tour
je l'ai fait Charlie dans mes rêves 4 et
hop la tour et après le pion est très
très fort très très chaud donc on va
voir ce qu'on jouer les joueurs on va
retourner donc B4 qu'est-ce qu'il a
trouvé Magnus pour poser les soucis il a
fait F4
pour embrouiller
c'est un drame et F5 il a trouvé une
autre façon de faire
c'est beau aussi et chaud parce qu'il y
a plus d'échecs sur son donc il menace
maths F6 Rochette d'un point
donc le coup qui fait sens c'est dames
me semble-t-il et tout
attends attends je peux me faire mater
hein
je veux pas perdre
j'ai peur quoi de perdre
mais maintenant il y a F6 roi achète
d'un meuf 8
et là il y a peut-être nul en sacrifiant
la dame par dame prend le 5 encore une
fois tu sacrifié
ils sont chauds les joueurs parce qu'ils
ont ils ont trouvé ça mais très très
rapidement c'est fou possible
Magnus il a pas de bol il a pas la
réussite parce qu'il a perdu en début de
tournoi j'ai l'impression qu'ils jouent
bien et là les deux dernières parties
les mecs ont super bien joué alors on
sait ils sont capables de super bien
jouer mais praguières il avait pas très
bien joué et là il sort une énorme
partie contre Magnus et voilà
fin du design et Magnus il est perpète
voilà du coup Adam non c'est pas c'est
pas un problème on peut on peut se lever
pendant la partie donc il a joué son cou
et il s'est levé ah ouais il a le droit
d'aller au toilettes il y a le droit de
manger tu dois gérer ton temps comme tu
veux alors comme tu le vois à la pendule
le
chrono
le chrono de Prague est actif
mais il a pas 4 minutes 40 en fait il a
50 minutes 40 puisque là ils ont passé
le 40e coup donc il va y avoir un rajout
de 50 minutes c'est la cadence du
tournoi qui est comme ça
alors dans la partie la plus fade de la
journée Wesley Sceaux avait fait un
début modeste il a bloqué Adou sa torov
qui donc a fait nul avec les pièces
noires brillamment à 1200
acceptés ce sont bien passés pour lui la
bloqué avec le gambida m'a accepté donc
c'est une ouverture que je conseille
pour les joueurs à 20h je l'aime
beaucoup n'hésitez pas à jouer comme un
d'où ça t'auras le gambida m'a accepté
super ouverture ça demande du travail
mais c'est pas insurmontable pour les
joueurs amateurs il y a pas tant que ça
de chapitre voilà on vous demande pas de
connaître la théorie comme abdoussac
aura chez Magnus ma ça ça fait des
échecs en fait dès que le roi va aller
en F
dam F4 et si je veux amener mon roi en e
je vais me faire prendre la tour sur
échec donc là
on est parti pour la nul
il va pas y avoir de grands suspens je
pense Laurie
rapidement l'annule signé entre Abdou et
SOS ok merci
[Musique]
un petit peu voilà très très rapidement
donc qu'est-ce que ça donne notre partie
est-ce que Van forest arrive à mettre la
pression G4
F5 pourtant j'avais dit qu'il fallait
mettre sur le noir c'est pion ça aurait
été mieux il y a peut-être pas moyen
j'aurais bien essayé de louer ça mais
ça semblait quand même logique
mais vous voyez
il y avait sans doute 3 à 3
et si on l'a donc je suis obligé de
perdre du temps donc c'est pas si facile
c'est dur dur dur dur dur
trouver trois c'est lent quand même
Fatou donc ça nous pas si facile qu'on
va voir mais prochainement nul si les
pions avance sur blanc on va se les
faire fixer le Roi peut rentrer
peut-être après
Fatou elle voit son qualité d'avance
et tu vas pas loin de jouer pour quelque
chose si ça continue
attention de Jordan mais ils ont pas
assez quand même leur
et les joueurs ont fini les notes
ça vient de faire nul vous voyez les
notes amène
des dénouement tout simplement
incroyable qui finit
blanc pour ces 6 jouets pour virer le
coup des 6
ca va laisser 5 le coma qu'on avait
annoncé
tourbé par Fabiano il a la perte de fou
il a presser mais qui est mère a toute
prouvé visiblement faut O2 on presse C4
et full et 7 on accepte de lâcher C4
pour échanger sans doute les pièces et
annuler la position donc il n'a pas
voulu tout à 8 pour garder son pressing
cavalier des trois
et maintenant la défense est stabilisée
et répétition de coût choisi par Fabiano
s'il a quand même une meilleure activité
de pierres mais le pion d'avance c'est
beaucoup OK
bon ben propre la partie de caméra on
regardera je vous invite à regarder le
début c'est peut-être théorique mais ça
nous a fait rigoler quand même c'est
quatre pions de camembert dans cet
Espagnol qui avait une tête
traditionnelle et après des cinq c'était
d'un coup moins tradi voilà c'est assez
original mais c'est je pense que c'est
ce qui est le plus plaisant toujours les
mêmes choses et ben je me suis posé la
question rollinoche
[Musique]
et oui stouf Kemer fera pas la fermeture
mais c'est pas non plus aujourd'hui
ni pour Abdou et je me pose une question
c'est vrai et donc on me la relaie de
roi F2 d'un F4 ça bouffe et chèque
et ce qu'on peut encore jouer cette
position Fatou on essayant de se
rapprocher peut-être de ses pions là
parce qu'on est assez menaces encore
roi des trois
est-ce qu'il y a une perpette intégrale
ou pas déjà parce que je peux aussi
croquer si
mais
il n'y a pas de
pions passer des deux côtés je suis un
peu plus avancé
il veut jouer en tout cas il n'a pas dit
son dernier mot il aurait pu déjà
prendre mieux
et oui c'est vrai c'est vrai Fatou qu'on
te voit presque plus il fait nuit à 18h
aussi donc et oui oui oui oui oui
à rester le Dax effectivement et oui
alors réglage technique et vous allez
voir
et la lumière fut
fut
alors du coup qu'est-ce qu'on va aller
voir donc là on aura cette partie je
pense vraiment que ça va faire nul mais
il y a un petit peu de travail encore
une nul contre Magnus ça se mérite mais
on peut pas faire échec partout là Dame
des 5 ah non il veut sur Dame des cinq
roisés 3 et dame 5 jours à C4 et ainsi
de suite déjà j'avance et puis je te
carotte donc peut-être que prévoit
devoir se résoudre à jouer dans F6 ça
doit être encore nul mais le Champion du
Monde Magnus et c'est la qualité quand
même des des gros joueurs comme ça ils
jouent on joue on joue là
pour bien bloquer les cases
c'est moins sympa tout à l'heure quand
même l'histoire ok alors on va aller sur
les parties qu'on a moins vues on a
suivi les joueurs qui sont en tête mais
il y a d'autres parties
Richard importe on l'a quitté très très
loin contre c'est intéressant quand même
de regarder ce que dit Rennes fait
contre
je sais pas si c'est le challenger on va
dire ça en fait il n'est pas non plus
candidat mondial il est prétendant titre
mondial prochainement contre Yann et
pomachi dans le match on va vouloir
suivre même si on peut regretter
l'absence de Magnus 45 ultra dominant
donc cavalier 3 d'accord tout refuide
les deux joueurs essaient de s'activer
on a la paire de fou contre un jeu actif
voilà on bloque
les Noirs semblent bloqués manœuvre de
cavalier
on améliore les pièces des deux côtés et
ça y est descendre le coup logique pour
se ouais activer sa paire de fou
mais ça donne quand même l'option
centrale qui joue pour le gain je sais
même pas te dire Fatou j'ai l'impression
que c'est quand même plutôt dans cette
position les blancs avec le pion de plus
j'ai quand même G2 en l'air pour la
finale on a envie de dire les blancs
et regarde ça j'aime beaucoup le coup
jouer fou B4 l'intelligence de Richard
rapporte plus de paire de fou man ok
donc c'est vraiment la Richard rapporte
parce qu'il a fixé en plus cette
majorité c'est Richard qui joue pour le
gain cavalier 3 fou B7 B3 en avant les
histoires avec la majorité tout re 8 hop
on échange et s'écartes c'est parti bref
on active les rois G5 très malin il dit
je veux mon pion passé
prends-moi en liquide il a pas pris mais
il a quand même le pion passé maintenant
digne
voici tous
1 et attention il a les pièces sont
protégées le pion non protégé pourquoi
c'est une erreur tout ça c'est encore
plus
j'avais envie de jouer ou le modèle 3 F7
mais je joue aligner c'est gagné ou
aligner ses paumé plutôt
[Musique]
alors là il y a quoi
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
dingue
on n'est pas loin de se prendre des
cavaliers G4
je crois que gagne intuitivement
ouais c'est joué par Richard rapporte
oui parce que sur roi des 6 j'écris un
chèque ou prendre G4 cavaliers
plus de 15
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué du coup ding ding
ding aïe aïe aïe
et oui roi des 6 oh là là la pauvre
digne
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a trouvé comme
gain roi des 6 il a joué cavalier 5
échecs je pensais que c'était cavalier
ah oui et j'ai donné un faux gain
regarde tout cavalier prend un chien pas
du tout il y a fou projet 4 et sur
cavalier chaque Richard par contre il
est sérieux cavalier F5 et chaque c'est
une autre histoire
donc maintenant je joue entre Roissy 7
et Roissy 5 voilà roi C7 et là je te
colle le petit cavalier E5
donc c'est voilà ce qui va se passer le
cavalier 5
est-ce qu'on peut parler des
signaux de position
c'est tout à fait ça
a craqué un super parti de Richard
rapporte mais
mais pour Ding c'est dur de finir le 40e
coup sur une perte de pièces comme ça
et maintenant c'est 1-0
sur le 40e en plus il peut être content
Richard
grosse partie grosse partie franchement
aujourd'hui
bien sûr même le
et ça m'est arrivé de déconner ou de
voir mes adversaires complètement
déconnés je me rappelle à moins 10 à
mettre un seul à voir laissé un mat
aider en deux coups enfin c'était
l'horreur pour lui l'horreur absolue G4
le coup pragmatique de Digne mais bon là
c'est complètement foutu complètement
foutu quelle chance Richard rapporte y
va il va tout prendre
[Musique]
on va revenir
ça peut faire ça des fois un petit peu
on a un petit peu lagué
voilà
donc on y voit plus clair qu'à rognon ça
donne quoi
ça donne
ça donne car rognon et
sous pression
mais ça va être nul quand même cette
position normalement
je vais gagner ça tu vas gagner ça
et tu auras pas la tour derrière ton
pion
donc du coup ça va être très très
difficile de promouvoir ce pion là moi
je vais mettre derrière le pion comme ça
on va faire à la queue leu leu la
et je peux pas trop partir avec mon roi
parce que sinon je me fais stopper les
pions de ce côté ok de toute façon c'est
la fin du zinote on voit qu'il y a un
petit pressing tenté par Google Fatou
mais normalement dans cette finale de
tour c'est pas assez
j'ai fait 10 ans d'allemand enfin tout
mais je dévalorise pas là d'un coup
l'acrobate contre max doudou
voilà c'est beaucoup plus chaud que
du coup
c'est la tour de plus
et de toute façon il y a pas le choix
donc on voit digne complètement dès
qu'on en sait pas là c'est tout de suite
en fait regardez
je suis obligé d'échanger les dames
et là je suis obligé de m'appliquer
alors il y a juste une idée c'est B2
mais même tout gage je crois je peux me
jouer fois trois sacrifier sur B2 je
vais tours C5
même ça doit être gagnant je pense et ce
que j'ai mieux
même peut-être tours c'est un tour B1
défense passive ça doit être pas mal
[Musique]
pourquoi pas jouer je mets juste ma tour
derrière le pion et ça gagne non
j'ai même pas j'ai besoin de jouer
passif pour ces 5 ça doit être bien non
qu'est-ce que tu en penses Fatou
pour ces cinq salaires sérieux pour C7
aussi c'est sérieux peut-être tours
c'est ça c'est plus précis ton C7
espérer la complication poussée 3 enfin
pas du tout il faut F6 donc tours 7
voilà comment on va se finir cette
partie il a pris d'ailleurs
c'est plus sérieux
la vérité d'un tournoi et celle d'un
autre pour des joueurs comme ça
ouais je crois qu'il peut tout à fait se
refaire il a le temps encore c'est pas
c'est pas à toi juste avant il y a des
mois encore de préparation derrière mais
oui
c'est certain que c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas cool pour lui donc
là
maxouglou qu'on voyait pas du tout à ce
niveau là dans la compétition ben il est
en train en terme de classements de de
faire quelque chose de grand parce qu'il
va gagner il va se rapprocher de la
sixième place de levona rognan
un gros tournois pour Max zoo de loup
parce que c'est dur comme tournoi donc
vous cache à rognon va y avoir une
petite finale de train vers rail max
doudou Erika easy max the loup va gagner
rapport qui vient de piquer une pièce il
va il va gagner
il va tenir ça nul je pense pas sûr mais
je pense et Carlsen ça joue encore d'un
point F6 jouer un et d'un E8 et Magnus
il va essayer de jouer cette finale de
dames c'est très intéressant pour
l'aspect technique et je pense que c'est
Magnus qui va fermer le la salle
aujourd'hui s'il a vraiment envie de
pousser cette finale de dames c'est très
long à se décanter tout on ne vient de
finir les iotes je te propose de faire
la deuxième pause de ce stream comme ça
on aura prévenu les viewers si ça te va
enfin tout bien sûr
on va voir si la régie voilà
[Musique]
me répond
ok alors
rapidement mais il n'a pas voulu
il n'a pas voulu faut pas être faut pas
être pressé du coup de toute façon on
n'est pas pressé on a toute la soirée
jusqu'à 21h si besoin on sera là on va
on va suivre ces cette partie cette
finale bah surtout en plus les matchs
bon on va pas se mentir si c'était une
finale vraiment une intéresse de deux
joueurs un peu largués bon ce serait
moins funky mais là vraiment ça nous
fait plaisir de regarder la technique de
carcène la partie d'hier était un peu
chiante avec Wesley Sow mais on apprend
plein de choses chiante dans le sens
c'est c'est pas des parties fantas c'est
pas des superbes parties comme on a vu
la plus belle partie d'aujourd'hui pour
moi c'était vent de Forest contre contre
l'ami guéri où ça à bastonné sévère il y
avait de l'attaque les joueurs se sont
trompés dès que les joueurs se trompent
on aime ça veut dire les positions sont
complexes
là ça fait longtemps que les deux
joueurs jouent les meilleurs coups il y
avait des petits calculs à faire quand
même mais c'est une partie plus plate
dommage parce que Maggie ça failli
réussir à faire la torture mais à titre
perso enfin tout je suis content
d'apprendre des meilleurs dans ces
finales même égal ils vont jouer de
manière très précise et ça va être
intéressant de voir si on arrive à
trouver les coûts
qui donnent plus de 100 litres d'eau
mais c'est toujours intéressant et
si parfois mais elle est pas si
équilibrée Fatou tu vois c'est pas un
trois contre trois sur la même aile ou
ok c'est enfin là ce sont nos nul on
voit la jauge etc mais il y a des
équipes qui permettent de de faire des
choses d'ailleurs s'il continue Magnus
c'est qu'il estime que il peut battre le
petit haut dans la finale même si à mon
avis Prague il a une expérience quand
même malgré son jeune âge et il va pas
se laisser faire il a fait une très
jolie partie aujourd'hui Prague pour
faire plaisir à tout qui nous a rejoint
dans le chat
est-ce que
est-ce que tu as vu si Vanessa
avait répondu
ce que tu as vu ça ou pas que
alors c'est vrai que j'ai pas fait de
pub aujourd'hui d'ailleurs elle m'a
répondu ok donc avant de demander le
petit break j'en profite pour faire les
pubs on peut en faire aussi pour tout
qui a une chaîne Youtube une chaîne
twitch donc n'hésitez pas à les
rejoindre et du coup je fais un petit
peu de pub aussi pour évolution échec
donc n'hésitez pas à aller voir la
plateforme de cours de Pro Évolution du
coup à chaque fois je vous mets le
cadeau maintenant comme ça vous
inscrivez vous voyez un petit peu ce que
ça donne et si ça vous plaît il y aura
plein de packs vidéos sur différents
sujets comme les ouvertures le milieu de
jeu pour les amateurs et les confirmer
je vous mets le cadeau dans le chat
comme ça pendant
la pub lancée par Vanessa vous pouvez
aller voir et je vais faire un saut
Vertou comme ça vous aurez si je réussis
et oui j'ai été bon ouais des fois je
fais quand même des ratés je m'y reprend
à deux fois quoi je réussis toujours
mais des fois je fais un truc un peu
ridicule avant et après ça marche mais
là c'est bon j'ai réussi du premier coup
donc vous avez le saut vers la chaîne
première évolution échec vous avez le
saut vers la chaîne de stouf et le
cadeau pour ceux qui veulent découvrir
la plateforme de cours donc vous êtes
vous êtes nickel et stuff il a une
chaîne Youtube aussi tout vous fait
chèque pour évolution échec sur Youtube
vous trouverez aussi donc il y a plein
de choses pour ceux qui veulent nous
rejoindre et nous suivre tout simplement
ça nous fera bien plaisir ça fera
grandir les communautés et c'est ce
qu'on recherche donc n'hésitez pas ok je
donne le goût à Vanessa et du coup on va
vous quitter sans vous dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]